abstention pardon donc il est adopté je
mets aux voix l'article premier bis
qui est pour l'article premier bis si
modifié
qui est contre
il y a-t-il abstention il est adopté
comme ça ne vous a pas échappé l'article
2 et réservé jusqu'à la fin de l'examen
du texte nous passons l'article 3 sur
lequel le président rotaïwa demandé la
parole
merci monsieur le Président l'article 3
monsieur le ministre c'est la clé de
voûte de l'Alpe
et si je souhaitais prendre la parole
c'est à la fois pour vous répondre
répondre à l'article de ce matin qu'on a
tous lu répondre à vos propos tout à
l'heure mais aussi pour préciser notre
pensée pour la préciser pour aujourd'hui
et pour demain pour la commission
expertmanente je ne reviens pas sur le
fait et nous le pensons tous ici sur ces
bancs quelle que soit les bancs sur
lesquels nous sommes assis que 413
milliards d'euros ça n'est pas rien
c'est un vrai effort simplement nous
voulons
dans cet article lever un doute un doute
qui est lié à une incertitude un doute
qui est lié aussi à une facilité
l'incertitude ce sont les crédits qui ne
sont pas budgétés
ça n'est pas nous qui l'avons pointé
c'est le Haut conseil ou finances
publiques et notre trajectoire a un
mérite c'est que il matérialise c'est un
joueur matérialiste concrétise les 7,4
milliards qui ne sont pas
et le doute lié évidemment au reste
c'est à dire à la facilité c'est que
l'essentiel
de l'effort est reporté après 2027 et
nous on veut que ça soit une progression
qui soit linéaire parce que sinon c'est
le même effort les mêmes marches que la
LPM actuelle
parce que c'est maintenant la guerre
c'est maintenant qu'on doit faire un
effort parce que c'est maintenant
l'inflation que l'euro d'aujourd'hui n'a
pas la même valeur il vaut plus que
l'euro de demain voilà ce que je voulais
vous dire et on veut s'assurer dans un
monde chaotique et nous ne sommes pas du
tout d'accord avec les 420 milliards que
vous avez cité c'est 413 milliards et
d'ailleurs nous l'avons vérifié aussi
avec notre commission des finances c'est
notre façon de compter l'argent public
et d'ailleurs si nous avons lu si nous
avions voulu sortir de l'enveloppe alors
dans le premier alinéa de l'article 3
nous n'aurions pas inscrit 413 milliards
mais 420 donc mes collègues mes chers
collègues ont modifie le cadencement
mais on reste dans l'enveloppe décrite
définie à Mont-de-Marsan par le
Président de la République je tenais à
le dire sur le même
donc sur cet article 3 nous avons quatre
amendements discussion communes le
premier le 66 qui est présenté par notre
collecte des skinny qui est la parole
merci Michel président monsieur le
ministre mesdames des ministres le
président de la commission
ce ministre par cet amendement nous
voulons simplement vous avez fait une
large communication sur les efforts
jamais réalisés sur des lois de
programmation militaire nous voulons
simplement ramener à sa juste proportion
cet effort budgétaire le chevauche
bankalembert des deux lois de
programmation militaire permet au
gouvernement de budgétiser sur les
exercices 2024 et 2025 dans les deux
lois de programmation militaire dans la
LPM
2019-2025 on estime à 97 milliards ce
qui était prévu pour les budgets 2024 et
2025 ils n'ont jamais été budgétisé
parce que d'abord il y a eu une absence
de véritable
réactualisation en 2021 mais ça c'était
un autre ministre pas vous et puis les
courtement de l'actuel loi de
programmation militaire amène à cela les
crédits
2019-2025 il devait être de 285
milliards ils seront tout simplement
pour 2019-2023 de 198 milliards la loi
de programmation militaire 2024 2030
réaffe ainsi les 97 milliards que j'ai
cité l'effort réel serait donc de 303
milliards auxquels il faudra un jour
soustraire l'inflation d'à peu près 30
milliards que au service et que le
gouvernement ont estimé
merci chers collègues ensuite
l'amendement 282 du gouvernement
[Musique]
un aléa dont nul ne sait aussi ce qu'il
deviendra est-ce que au fond les
facteurs macroéconomiques se retournent
auquel cas ça sera une bonne nouvelle
puisque
projection sont plutôt prudentes dans
les critères que nous avons retenus ou
est-ce qu'auquel cas ça s'aggrave et je
vais vous dire une chose mais Center si
ça s'aggrave ça s'arrivera pour
l'ensemble du budget de l'État et pour
d'autres programmes et on aura
l'occasion de toute façon dire et au
regard monsieur le Président Cambon des
engagements que nous avons pris de
documenter l'inflation année par année
en loi de finance des de toute façon les
documents budgétaires annuels vous
verrez les impacts sur l'inflation et
vous les constaterez d'ailleurs sur ce
qu'on appelle le physique c'est-à-dire
en clair de voir des décalages de
commandes ce que vous n'avez pas
constaté jusqu'à l'or première famille
de sujet l'inflation on est revenu de
nombreux soins en commission mais je
voulais le refaire devant vous deuxième
sujet qui est la deuxième partie du
propos du président Retailleau
c'est la dynamique ou le rythme en
quelque sorte de l'effort budgétaire
alors il y a j'ai envie de dire il y a
là il y a la politique au sens noble du
terme ou évidemment quand vous dites que
l'essentiel de l'effort est après 2027
comme moi je regarde depuis 2017 je vois
quand même deux tiers d'efforts entre
2017 et 2027 mais je reviendrai dans un
instant et donc je considère que cette
trajectoire là évidemment elle n'est pas
la même marche comme on le dit puisque
dans un escalier si vous montez sur la
même marche globalement vous faites du
sur place et qu'on est bien sur 3
milliards qui s'ajoutent à chaque fois
après il y a la dynamique de cette de
ces marches sur lequel on pourrait
revenir et il y a un troisième sujet je
les découpe en morceaux pour ils se
rencontrent mais ne sont pas
complètement joints c'est la somme
globale de l'enveloppe et là monsieur le
Président retaillou vous dites en tout
cas au nom de la majorité que vous avez
l'honneur de du groupe que vous avez
l'honneur de conduire de présider que
vous restez dans l'enveloppe des 413 ma
difficulté
peut-être aussi cet article ces
interviews de ce matin c'est que nous
dans notre manière de non monsieur le
Président quand certains membres de
votre groupe tweet quelques minutes
après le discours du président de la
République à Mont-de-Marsan c'est un
terrain je ne m'en offusque pas lorsque
le Sénat est de bonne guerre trouve que
le texte manque d'ambition je ne m'en
office que pas donc c'est aussi le jeu
démocratique vous avez une lecture et un
avis sur le projet de loi porté par le
gouvernement le gouvernement peut avoir
un avis sur le texte tel qu'il sort de
la commission ça me semble sain au
contraire que ces lieux ça a eu lieu en
commission par trois fois sous
l'autorité du président Cambon et j'en
informe aussi nos concitoyens il y a pas
d'agressivité vous le savez très bien
non en revanche techniquement je veux
quand même vous partager la manière dont
on lit le chiffre après on verra ça
peut-être à d'autres débats plus
politiques dans un autre cadre mais je
pense utile de de re détailler la copie
du gouvernement
ce que j'ai fait par courrier en date du
2 juin dernier que j'ai adressé un
certain nombre d'entre vous pour
réexpliquer comment l'affaire était
monté vous avez 400 milliards d'euros de
crédits budgétaires pour 413,3 milliards
d'euros de besoins militaires cette
distinction elle se documente par 13,3
milliards d'euros que l'on découpe de la
manière suivante
5,9 milliards d'euros de ressources
extra budgétaires dont on estime
désormais qu'elles sont sécurisées une
ombre débats sur le sujet et ça on est
d'accord on les retrouvera tout à
l'heure ensuite nous avons 1,2 milliards
d'euros qui est une des parts du
financement de l'Ukraine vous avez en
tête qu'il y a trois modalités de
financement différente l'Ukraine là on
est sur les prélèvements du parc des
armées qui donnent lieu à une
recomplètement par du matériel neuf en
clair quand on sort un ami disrc ou
lorsqu'on sort un Crostage c'est
remplacé par un jaguar dans le premier
cas et par un VL Mika dans l'autre cas
on a donc touché au format des armées
lesquelles matériel même s'ils sont
anciens étaient encore dans la cible
capacitaire pour au moins 2030 voire
2035 et donc c'est là on a provisionné
1,2 milliards d'euros pour l'Ukraine et
puis ensuite on a 6,2 milliards d'euros
de 2 outils différents d'ailleurs un qui
est un outil qu'elle report de charge on
nous a suffisamment reproché de ne pas
suffisamment bien gérer l'inflation pour
désormais balayer d'un revers de main
l'outil qui de tout temps permet de
gérer l'inflation et la deuxième des
choses les marges frictionnelles qui
sont au fond les retards qui sont déjà
intégrés dans la copie des 413 milliards
alors avec du recul bien mon appris de
faire se distinguer puisqu'en fait il se
trouve et là même si je suis pour rien
je le soufflait à l'oreille de mon
voisin il se trouve que dans les
programmations militaires précédentes ça
a toujours été construit comme ça sauf
que ça n'était jamais montré au
Parlement
pour des raisons que je vous laisse
deviner et si je peux vous donner un
exemple très concret que la loi de
programmation militaire actuelle celle
dans lequel nous sommes encore sous
l'Empire vous aviez voté 295 milliards
d'euros de ressources budgétaires
c'était donc une LPM à 295 milliards
d'euros sauf que nous étions à 304
milliards d'euros de besoins militaires
et ce 3004 n'avait pas été montré au
Parlement et donc ce que j'ai souhaité
au regard des sommes importantes qui
sont en jeu désormais dans ces
programmations et aussi parce que c'est
la modification on en a suffisamment
discuté avec les uns et les autres dans
le tableau capacitaire c'est pas tant
les commandes qui nous intéressent mais
réellement ce qui est livré aux forces
armées c'est de repartir du besoin
militaire et en face ils mettent les
ressources budgétaires qu'elle soit
extra ce budgétaires ou sur le budget de
la Nation ce qui nous amène à la lecture
de ce qui a été modifié en commission je
parle pas des marches ou du rythme je
sors les marchés et le rythme de nos de
nos conversations le temps d'un instant
la copie du en tout cas tel qu'elle
existe au moment où je vous parle c'est
407,4 milliards d'euros de crédit
budgétaire
auquel s'ajoute toujours les 5,9
milliards d'euros de ressources extra
budgétaires et auquel s'ajoute toujours
les 7,4 milliards d'euros de charge
parce qu'ils sont dans la programmation
donc en fait mais si ils sont dans la
programmation ou alors ça revient les
compter deux fois donc vous les comptez
deux fois mais non on les compte qu'une
seule fois puisqu'ils sont dans les 413
mais non ils sont par définition on a
déjà des indications sur des retards
alors très bien monsieur le Président
Retailleau allez je prends le problème
par l'autre bout si vous ne partagez pas
cette lecture là je vais dans l'autre
sens vous avez déjà 413 milliards
d'euros dans le tableau capacitaire
il se trouve que la Commission a déjà
rajouté un milliard d'euros pour
l'entraînement 200 millions d'euros pour
les ressources humaines et des
amendements à venir table sur 2
milliards d'euros de plus de capacités
ça veut dire que déjà même si vous ne
partagez pas ma lecture sur les marges
sectionnelles nous sommes déjà à 3,2
milliards d'euros en plus des 413 alors
là vous allez me dire non on reste à 413
là c'est le moment de la vérité parce
que si vous restez à 413 avec plus de
MCO plus de moyens capacitaires et plus
d'entraînement ça veut dire qu'il y a
des renoncements quelque part et donc là
pour le coup je vous le dis si vous êtes
à 416,2 ma lecture est à 420 mais si
vous ne partagez pas je l'abandonne
n'est pas un instant et si on reste sur
416,2 ça veut donc dire que ces 3,2
milliards il faut bien les trouver
quelque part donc soit vous êtes
au-dessus de 413
soyez des renoncements sur d'autres
postes mais il y a pas il y a pas
d'argent magique comme dirait quelqu'un
que je connais bien qui m'a nommé et
donc je le dis non mais comprenez bien
mon état d'esprit n'est pas à la
polémique je le dis sincèrement je dis
juste que c'est compliqué sur une
programmation comme celle-ci de ne pas
s'accorder techniquement sur la lecture
des chiffres donc je l'ai écrit je l'ai
répété c'est pas nouveau monsieur le
Président Retailleau quand le ministre
Longué qui est membre de votre groupe
était ministre de la Défense les marches
frictionnelles existaient déjà quand à
la Richard pardonnez-moi madame la
Présidente je pensais qu'il présait
toujours la séance était ministre de la
Défense les marges frictionnelles
existaient déjà quand Jean-Pierre
Raffarin présidé la Commission et qu'il
était premier ministre les marches
frictionnelles existaient déjà donc je
n'ai fait que montrer une méthodologie
qui est vieille comme Hérode mais
au-delà même de la méthodologie vieille
comme Hérode il y a une réalité c'est
que vous avez décidé mais vous êtes
parlementaire est complètement souverain
dans cette manière de faire je le je le
respecte mais on est des 413 et ça pour
le coup je le dis je suis pas Premier
ministre où ministre du budget mais
évidemment ça pose des questions pour la
soutenabilité budgétaire globale donc ça
c'est un point important parce que il y
a l'inflation il y a les marches et il y
a l'enveloppe globale et sur l'enveloppe
globale soit il y a une lecture on est à
416,2 c'est factuel la colonne des
dépenses a augmenté en commission ça je
veux bien tout ce qu'on veut mais c'est
têtu et de l'autre côté au-delà de cela
par définition on a une lecture sur les
marges frictionnelles qui n'ont pas
disparu parce qu'il ne s'agit pas de les
budgétés pour qu'elle disparaissent
donc moi je suis prêt évidemment s'il
faut même suspendre pour avoir une
réunion sur le sujet je leur ai bien
volonté de nouveau parce que je veux
vraiment montrer la bonne foi du
gouvernement dans cette manière de faire
je pense que l'exécution à l'euro près
de la LPM désormais nous oblige
justement à être rigoureux sur sur le
sujet en tout cas moi je reste à la
disposition de du Sénat pour nous
entendre sur ce sujet dont nous ne
faisons pas un préalable politique ou
politicien mais bel et bien un élément
de clarification important si on reste à
413 milliards c'est donc 413 milliards
de dépenses or là au moment où je vous
parle on est déjà au moins à 416,2 si ce
n'est à 420 donc l'amendement est
défendu sur le contenu il remet les
marches et la trajectoire telle qu'elle
était présentée à l'assemblée enfin vous
l'avez compris c'est pas tant que la
trajectoire et les marches c'était aussi
l'amendement d'appel pour avoir cette
conversation et cette discussion et ce
débat noble sur les trois aspects
inflation marche mais surtout enveloppe
globale désormais puisque là il y a un
enjeu de soutenabilité qui m'inquiète
beaucoup
non monsieur Perrin
non non
l'amendement numéro 6 monsieur deleige
au nom de la commission des finances
merci madame la Présidente oui j'ai
effectivement souhaité à nouveau
présenter cet amendement de la
commission des finances pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord pour soutenir la
commission de la défense sur le chiffre
de 407 milliards c'est notre analyse
aussi à la commission des finances je
tiens le dire la deuxième raison c'est
que nous considérons que on ne peut pas
reporter l'effort au prochain
quinquennat mais à cela s'ajoute
d'autres arguments monsieur le ministre
c'est que j'entends bien toutes les
arguties de Bercy en a même vu un haut
gradé faire le tour des sénateurs pour
nous donner des leçons de calcul
budgétaires on s'en serait bien
indispensé mais je dois dire que votre
explication ne nous a pas plus convaincu
parce que ça reviendrait à dire que au
fond on finance une partie de l'objectif
capacitaire
en espérant qu'on ne va pas l'atteindre
ou pire qu'on va tout faire pour
différer soit les paiements soit les
livraisons et il s'en suit forcément
qu'à un moment ou un autre il y aura une
conséquence sur la loi de programmation
du finances publiques qui dès le même se
trouvera frappé de la même insécurité et
si vous ne souhaitez pas le mot
insincérité disons du même doute je
voudrais profiter monsieur le ministre
de cet amendement pour vous poser deux
questions la première dans quelles
conditions nous allons rentrer dans la
nouvelle loi de programmation militaire
par rapport au report de charge parce
que ceci n'est pas tout à fait neutre
sauf erreur de ma part c'est 5 milliards
ça veut donc dire qu'il y a la 5
milliards de cavaleries qui s'ajoutent
au 7 que vous voulez nous expliquer
qui n'existerait pas et puis j'ai
souvenir que en avril dans un interview
vous avez déclaré que en 2013 2023 le
budget de la défense serait abondé d'un
milliard 5 vous pouvez nous en dire un
petit peu plus sur ce milliard 5 je vous
remercie merci la maman 67 monsieur
todéchini
la pédagogie c'est la répétition je vous
permette de répéter vous nous avez pas
convaincu cet amendement vise simplement
à vouloir neutraliser les effets de
l'inflation et de permettre que les
montants programmés soient effectivement
ceux qui seront perçus par nos armées
vous avez évalué je dis tout à l'heure à
30 milliards
les sommes qui seront consacrées à
l'inflation pour 2024 à 2030 la seule
solution trouvée elle a été cité déjà
c'est d'utiliser le report de charge
pour neutraliser ses effets de
l'inflation et donc
le respect à l'égard de nos armées et de
ce qui était prévu fait que la sincérité
de cette loi de programmation militaire
serait totale si elle était exprimé en
euros constant
merci alors l'avis de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
Président sur ces quatre amendements
merci madame la Présidente alors sur le
66 c'est amendement était satisfait
puisque je rappelle que en commission
nous avons adopté une nouvelle
trajectoire donc il est satisfait et je
propose que les auteurs que l'auteur de
l'amendement 66 puisse le retirer car
nous aurions dans ce cas là une
trajectoire différente de celle que nous
avons adoptée
sur le 282 monsieur le ministre donc
nous sommes là au cœur au cœur du débat
il y a quelque chose
il y a quelque chose que j'aimerais que
vous nous expliquer clairement de deux
choses l'une
je reprends votre répartition 413
milliards annoncés par le Président de
la République à Mont-de-Marsan repris
par tous les orateurs tout le monde a en
tête l'idée selon laquelle la nouvelle
LPM porte sur 413 milliards alors là
dessus vous nous dites 400 milliards
sont budgetés 5 milliards 9 font l'objet
de ressources qui sont bien identifiées
je les rappelle les ventes de fréquences
le produit de le produit des des soins
dispensés par les hôpitaux militaires la
vente de l'immobilier on les accepte ces
fameux 7 milliards c'est une étrange
méthode qui consiste à dire c'est 7
milliards ne font pas l'objet de budget
mais de ressources extra budgétaires
mais c'est quoi les ressources extra
budgétaires de deux choses l'une où on
peut les dépenser ou on ne peut pas les
dépenser où ils sont dans les quatre
vous nous dites ils sont dans les 400
milliards et vous les compter deux fois
non c'est ça qu'on n'arrive pas à saisir
c'est une vous avez imposé une nouvelle
méthode
pour pour évoquer ce sujet nous ce que
nous voulons c'est sécuriser être assuré
que 413 milliards vont être dépensés
pour le renforcement de nos forces
armées et pour nous les reports de
charge c'est un sujet que nous abordons
que nous détestons car nous savons très
bien ce qui se passe au la vue dans la
précédente LPM et quand on a demandé une
actualisation on s'est aperçu qu'il
manquait des milliards parce qu'on
n'arrêtait pas de reporter des chats
alors de deux choses l'une où on a 413
milliards à dépenser où on les a pas
c'est ça que c'est cette difficulté ou
cet arrangement
oratoire qui laisse à croire que le
Sénat veut dépenser plus nous maintenons
l'idée sur lequel et je suis prêt nous
sommes prêts en discuter avec vous nous
je pense ici qu'il y a le sentiment
unanime qui consiste à dire que on veut
rester dans l'enveloppe des 413
milliards mais on n'arrive pas à
comprendre comment vous pouvez dire il y
a des il y a 400 milliards qui sont
budgétiques il y a 7 milliards qui sont
des ressources extra budgétaires alors
vous nous parlez des marges
frictionnelles vous nous parlez des des
programmes qui sont en retard bah
écoutez si on les budget et qu'ils ne
sont pas
qu'ils ne sont pas exécutés dans les
lois budgétaires qui se succéderont vous
reprendrez ces chiffres j'ai repris la
comparaison que j'ai dit dans mon
intervention si vous commentez des A400M
qui ne vous sont pas livrés vous les
payez pas et donc vous avez cet argent
qui est disponible c'est ça que nous
n'arrivons pas à saisir avec par quel
subterfuge vous avez présenté cette
affaire il est le mieux va lui dire la
LPM c'est 400 milliards ou 400 5
milliards c'était clair tout le monde
aurait compris je pense qu'on se serait
pas livré depuis des semaines et des
mois à des débats et des exégèses sur le
fait de savoir où sont les justificatifs
futures des 7 milliards et demi donc
c'est pour cela que évidemment nous
maintenons notre amendement dans le
monde notre position et nous nous avons
nous émettons un avis défavorable à
l'amendement du Gouvernement parce que
nous souhaitons qu'il y ait des
éclaircissements complémentaires et que
l'on puisse évidemment en discuter
sur l'amendement numéro 6 de notre
qui propose une trajectoire dont les
deux premières années sont les mêmes que
celles qui sont proposées par le
gouvernement avec un effort
complémentaire là je sollicite notre
collègue pour que au nom de la
commission c'est amendement puisse être
retiré puisque nous avons adopté en
commission une autre trajectoire qui a
rassemblé la majorité de notre
commission c'est une accélération de
surcroît qui est souhaitable je le redis
c'est en ce moment que nous sommes n'ont
pas en guerre mais en situation
excessivement grave étendue par rapport
à l'Ukraine c'est en ce moment que nous
livrons des armes les armes que nous
livrons nous ne les avons plus et si
jamais il y avait un conflit de haute
intensité nous n'aurions plus à les amis
nous n'aurions pu les armures les ce
n'est pas le moment de baisser la garde
et c'est ce pourquoi cette accélération
est possible par ailleurs vous avez
quand même prévu entre 30 et 60
milliards d'effets d'inflation tout ce
qui est dépensé maintenant ne sera pas
sujet à l'érosion de l'inflation donc
c'est ce pourquoi
nous proposons que cet amendement 6
puisse faire l'objet d'un retrait sinon
la vie sera défavorable et l'amendement
67 relatif à l'adoption d'une
trajectoire en euro constant là c'est
évidemment un avis défavorable car pour
le coup ceci entraînerait une hausse de
30 à 60 milliards de recours en
supplémentaires là nous ne pouvons pas
rentrer dans cette logique même si nous
comprenons encore une fois le sens de
l'amendement et que comme vous l'avez
dit chaque année lors des budgets on
aura une idée précise du dérapage de
l'inflation donc avis défavorable sur le
la vie du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les signataires alors
si je reprends les amendements le 66 du
groupe socialiste présenté par le
ministre des skinny bon on peut prendre
les chiffres par tous les bouts si on ne
prend pas sur l'ensemble de la
programmation avec les chevauchements
d'années mais on avait déjà eu le débat
avec le cinquante mal en commission on
prend le budget annuel de la défense en
2017 on prend le budget annuel tel qu'on
le propose en 2030 et on voit qu'il a
doublé alors après
bah oui mais tel que rédigé l'amendement
on voit bien quand même qu'on cherche à
tourner autour du pot bon non mais je le
dis parce que allez je j'ai déjà répondu
plusieurs fois j'ai un lien pas sur
l'amendement du Gouvernement je crois
que j'ai dit ce qui avait à dire mais je
pourrais revenir à la faveur de la maman
de Monsieur Delhaize
bon déjà monsieur le sénateur je vois
que vous essayez de faire en sorte que
les deux premières annuités
correspondent aux deux premières unités
de notre programmation de finance
publique que vous avez voté c'est un
argument que je manie avec précaution
puisque ce que le Parlement a fait le
Parlement peut très bien l'adapter enfin
salut quand même la cohérence ou en tant
que commissaire au finance vous essayez
évidemment de vous assurer de la
soutenabilité de cette affaire et donc
vous proposez au fond dans les années
dans lesquelles la LPFP n'a pas encore
inscrit une somme si je comprends bien
d'accélérer au moment où justement cette
trajectoire n'a pas encore été adoptée
par le Parlement si j'ai bien compris
l'esprit de votre amendement en tout cas
je je mets un avis défavorable mais je
vois ce qu'intellectuellement vous vous
voulez faire
et qui pose la bonne question de la
soutenabilité pour nos finances
publiques sur le report des charges
globalement nous sommes à 4 milliards
d'euros au moment où nous parlons alors
quand le président comment on dit on a
Aurore des rapports de charges moins non
parce qu'en fait ça nous permet de
traiter l'inflation et c'est entendu
avec les industriels et en plus les
industriels bénéficient d'intérêt dans
cette affaire c'est à dire que on est
sur des tels programmes d'une telle
masse que le report de charge nous
permet aussi de déclencher la facture en
accord avec l'industriel au moment où
les critères macroéconomiques sont les
plus satisfaisants pour le contribuable
et je comprends pas l'acharnement sur le
report de charge les autres ministères
ce pardonnez-moi cette expression se
roulerait par terre pour avoir les mêmes
outils de gestion de l'inflexion que le
ministère des armées mieux que ça ce
sont souvent des outils qui ont été
suggérés par les parlementaires dans des
lois de programmation il y a 10-15 ou 20
ans considérant que les lois de
programme étaient telles on va revenir à
euro-courant au reconstan qu'il fallait
permettre à l'ordinateur des dépenses
pourvu qu'il le montre dans les lois
finances ce que nous faisons quel était
le mécanisme de report de charge enfin
je non mais alors budgétaire même
l'aéroport de charges c'est enfin je
n'arrive pas à comprendre je l'ai
expliqué de nombreuses reprises en
commission je l'ai écrit je veux bien
qu'on s'entraîne à cette mécanisme là
c'est un mécanisme qui est bénefique
pour les armées voilà pas dire mieux
interrogeons le ministre Richard le
ministre Longuet pour ceux de mes
prédécesseurs qui siège encore ici je
voilà je moi je le dis je défends pour
le coup ce mécanisme là quand Gérald
Darmanin et vote une vous fait voter
pardonnez-moi vous propose une lotte mi
il n'y a pas de mécanisme pour absorber
l'inflation sur la construction des
commissariats voilà nos élus locaux nos
mères et nos présentes départements
s'ils avaient un mécanisme de report de
charge pour déclencher le paiement sur
l'orginnase ou leur piscine de la même
manière que le ministère des armées
croyez moi il serait content donc moi je
le redis là je pense qu'il y a un
contresens à s'en prendre au mécanisme
des report de charge il est bon pour le
ministère si le Parlement veut le
supprimer très bien mais j'expliquerai
donc qu'on a supprimé quelque chose qui
était bon pour les finances du ministère
les retards monsieur le sénateur delène
les retards on les souhaite pas monsieur
monsieur le sénateur de la retards ne
les souhaite pas mais le charme d'une
programmation sur 7 ans c'est que si on
intègre pas déjà les retards
on serait un insincérité par rapport à
la copie pourquoi ces marges
frictionnelles existent tout simplement
parce que depuis 1960 on a suffisamment
de recul sur les différentes
programmations et donc
j'ai pas envie de prendre cet exemple
parce qu'il est malheureux mais s'il
peut permettre de nous de nous
comprendre c'est un peu le principe du
surbooking vu la masse des grands
programmes il est évident qu'à chaque
fois il y a un coefficient mais à chaque
fois il est constaté
mais pourquoi affaiblir la programmation
à repasser en unité budgétaire c'est la
force de la programmation c'est comme
pour les reports de charges alors
privons nous d'un outil supplémentaire
qui est utile pour le ministère des
armées mais je suis désolé je ferai pas
dans le Figaro la prochaine fois promis
mais je dirais non mais je prends vous
savez quand ça me connaît depuis le
temps mais sur le fond vous êtes en
train de non mais sur le fond oui sur le
fond on est en train de s'en prendre à
des outils qui sont bons pour le
ministère je
non vraiment je comprends plus donc là
dessus je je le dis il y a le sujet 413
au delà le sénateur président Retailleau
pardon a raison de dire vous n'avez pas
modifié l'alinéa pour l'aide primaire
pour l'être à la Linéa 1 de fait vous
n'avez pas modifié mais alors si je le
dis pour la suite des amendements qui
viendront et peut-être aussi pour faire
des amendements de correction en séance
quoi qu'il arrive même si vous ne
partagez pas ma lecture marche
frictionnelle report de charge le Sénat
a déjà alourdi la facture avec
d'ailleurs des mesures qui sont bonnes
mais qu'on ne s'est pas payé les trois
milliards d'eux que je parlais tout à
l'heure donc là moi je fais plus je suis
à votre disposition y compris dans un
cadre plus informel pour refaire le
contour de tout cela mais il est clair
qu'on est plus à 413 au moment où on se
parle ça je peux vous le signer dès
demain et et pas dans le Figaro et avec
beaucoup de bonnes foi et de manière
sincère bon quand au dernier amendement
sur recourant au reconstant non monsieur
le ministre
recours en reconstant alors c'est très
contradictoire en plus avec ce que vous
m'avez dit tout à l'heure sur
l'inflation c'est en clair on passe d'un
schéma où vous contestez nos hypothèses
potentielles pas contester mais en tout
cas vous émettez un doute une crainte
une crainte sur nos hypothèses en
matière d'inflation et en faisant la
transaction courant constant vous
écartez toute forme d'hypothèses sur
l'inflation et alors je ne veux pas une
deuxième fois le couteau dans la pluie
puisque le présent retaillou va
définitivement m'en vouloir mais jadis
et vous savez d'où je viens c'est comme
ça que le budget des armées a été
diminué c'est en faisant au recourant au
reconstant comme ça l'inflation venait
grignoter c'est comme ça que le budget
global diminué donc le présent combo en
raison de mettre un avis défavorable à
cet amendement parce qu'en fait il vient
quoi qu'on en dise caper l'ensemble des
efforts c'est pas qu'on rajoute 30 000
avant plus c'est que tout simplement on
évacue tout existence de l'inflation
dans notre affaire et là évidemment on
se prend l'ensemble du mur de
l'inflation en pleine impacte donc elle
vit défavorable pour cet
monsieur le ministre cette discussion en
fait elle permet juste un peu
d'embrouiller un peu plus les sénateurs
minimum on respecte la trajectoire
budgétaire la trajectoire et la cible
capacitaire définie dans la loi de
programmation militaire de votre
prédécesseur on aime parler et on oublie
quelque chose d'important dans cette
discussion depuis le départ c'est quand
même la courbe parce que évidemment on
parle de 413 milliards mais l'essentiel
pour nous c'est la courbe c'est-à-dire
la capacité qu'on aura dans les années
qui viennent à investir 600 millions
d'euros de plus que ce que vous avez
prévu c'est-à-dire le 3 milliards et
c'est 600 milliards d'euros que nous
souhaiterions nous souhaiterions voir
investi ils ont pour objectif justement
d'atteindre cette cible que nous avons
voté ici au Sénat à 98% en 2018 qui
consistait à atteindre une cible
capacitaire en 2025 et que compte tenu
de ce que vous nous annoncez aujourd'hui
malgré une augmentation de 40% du budget
on ne risque d'atteindre qu'en 2035 donc
moi je suis évidemment complètement
favorable à ce que nous votions cet
amendement pour évoquer essentiellement
aussi modifier cette trajectoire
budgétaire qui je le rappelle fera qu'un
euro de 2023 n'étant pas un euro 2030
nous pourrons acquérir beaucoup plus de
matériel merci Madame connu Mouret
oui merci madame la présidente Madame et
Monsieur le Ministre moi je ne veux pas
du tout entrer dans dans le débat sur le
détail du budget ni revenir d'ailleurs
sur le la démonstration très complexe
que vous nous avez faite mais qui ne
nous a pas vraiment convaincu puisque
finalement le dépassement dont vous
parlez n'est pas le fait de lissage qui
a été voté du lissage budgétaire qui a
été voté en commission mais d'ajout en
effet auquel d'ailleurs certains de vos
amendements participent alors votre
gouvernement a choisi d'utiliser le
terme d'économie de guerre c'est un
terme qui est plutôt fort et en même
temps vous proposez un effort budgétaire
pour plus tard alors que les besoins en
équipements sont maintenant donc nous
comprenons bien évidemment le dilemme de
Bercy aujourd'hui qui cherche à faire
des économies puisque le ministre le
maire a annoncé des économies de près de
5% pour l'ensemble des ministères mais
pour aller dans le sens de l'annonce
présidentielle avec une opinion publique
aujourd'hui qui est prête à accepter cet
effort assez substantiel en matière de
défense et bien nous pensons en effet
que il faut il faut dépenser cet argent
maintenant pour des équipements dont
nous avons besoin dans cet effort de
guerre merci monsieur le ministre des
chimie
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre voyez bien que le débat est
nécessaire je l'ai dit en Intervenance
d'abord sur l'amendement 66 que c'était
vous qui était rentré dans le débat avec
413 milliards vous en avez fait une
large communication tout le gouvernement
et c'était pour discuter de cela et
souligner tout cela que l'amendement 66
et 67 était déposés naturellement je
vais les retirer mais ça a permis le
débat ça permet en tout cas de d'essayer
de comprendre mais je crois que vous
parlez vous-même de dépassement des
propositions du Sénat des 413 milliards
je pense que quelques amendements que
vous avez déposés au nom du gouvernement
vont aussi aggraver un peu la facture
mais on y reviendra en cours de de débat
voilà donc les deux amendements sont
retirés merci monsieur delege
merci madame la Présidente sur le
ministre en fait on avait très bien
compris votre comparaison avec le
surbooking est parfait c'est un aveu le
prof du surbooking c'est que tout le
monde ne rentre pas dans l'avion à la
fin ça veut donc bien dire qu'à un
moment donné on n'aura pas la totalité
de ce que vous avez affiché en termes de
capacité à atteindre donc la marche
frictionnelle c'est une définition
élégante de crédit qui n'existe pas
j'en profite pour retirer
mon amendement parce que j'ai été plus
convaincu par les arguments de Monsieur
Cambon que par les votes ne m'en voulez
pas
Laurent
oui merci madame la Présidente nous nous
voterons enfin je sais pas combien il en
restera à l'arrivée nous ne vous
tromperons de ses amendements parce que
nous n'avons pas envie d'arbitrer ce
débat qui est quand même le bal des
hypocrites
nous avons en vérité je pense qu'il y a
un grand consensus sur la cible des 413
milliards
mais le gouvernement a du mal à assumer
ce choix
dans le budget
parce que il y a des arbitrages
budgétaires
compliqué qui sont la reconnaissance du
fait que il y a un arbitrage politique à
faire avec la nation sur la part des
richesses disponibles que nous sommes
capables de consacrer aux dépenses
militaires et le gouvernement a du mal à
assumer ce choix il y a eu des
arbitrages contradictoires on le sait
dans le gouvernement parce que la charge
est lourde et elle va peser très lourde
très lourdement donc le gouvernement a
trouvé un affichage des 413 milliards
qui lui permet de passer la rampe dans
ses compromis budgétaires et de l'autre
côté nous avons une majorité sénatoriale
qui s'acharne à sécuriser qui va le
faire tout au long du débat cette
trajectoire au nom du fait qu'il ne faut
qu'il faut être dans la sincérité et
j'en passe des meilleurs
les mêmes de la majorité sénatoriale qui
dès que nous allons entamer le débat
budgétaire redeviendront les champions
de l'orthodoxie budgétaire et de la
lutte contre la dette publique et donc
qui massacreront tous les autres budgets
après avoir sécurisé celui-là et bien
nous sommes en train de passer à côté
d'un débat qui mériterait quand même je
pense un grand débat politique avec la
nation c'est quelle est la part réelle
des richesses réelles du pays que nous
voulons consacrer à ces choix là mais en
même temps que nous voulons consacrer à
d'autres priorités nationales tout aussi
stratégiques y compris en matière de
souveraineté par exemple de souveraineté
industrielle par exemple de transition
climatique et de souveraineté
énergétique et je pourrais citer
beaucoup d'autres exemples mais nous
n'avons pas ce panorama
je le répète qui est quand même un peu
le bal des hypocrites
pour revenir sur les 413 effectivement
le mais on l'a évoqué des gens en
commission le souci du gouvernement
c'est que tous ces organisé
pour ceux qui avaient choisi
Mont-de-Marsan nous avions refusé nous
d'apparaître comme juste à côté de la
photo pour l'annonce du président sans
avoir parce que le Parlement n'avait pas
été consulté à l'époque et on voit bien
que les 413 c'est la fin la force du
gouvernement dans l'annonce mais son
boulet et qu'aujourd'hui tous tourne
autour de cela personne sait s'en sortir
bon une fois qu'on s'est dit ça je
rappelle juste
que en 2017 sur un élection
présidentielle donc en plus on parle là
juste de
2027 ans 2027 voilà chacun aura corrigé
et que de toute façon la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
aujourd'hui elle s'arrête en 2027 donc
on voit bien que le sujet qui est devant
nous va avant poser problème mais c'est
vrai que c'est d'ailleurs ce que prisait
le président du Haut Conseil des
finances publiques c'est que tout ça
tient jusqu'en 2027 mais de 27 à 30 nous
rentrons dans une dans un tunnel sans
que cette personne sache exactement ce
que sera la trajectoire des finances
publiques donc j'ai envie de dire Jojo
monsieur le monsieur ministre notre
souci nous c'est il vaut mieux dépenser
maintenant pour les programmes parce que
c'est sécurisé il faut dépenser
maintenant plus cuire la question de
l'inflation et puis il faut dépenser
maintenant parce que personne ne connaît
réellement et sincèrement la trachure
des finances publiques posent 2027 c'est
pour ça que encore une fois nous
souhaitons maintenir à ce stade la
trajectoire et puis il y aura le débat
des 7 milliards mais je crois comme il y
aura un débat qui aura une espèce de
d'être mené la commission d'expéritaire
je crois qu'on y participer à nous aussi
avec d'autres groupes et là je crois
qu'on arrivera les uns les autres à
garder l'essentiel et puis l'accessoire
sera mis de côté merci monsieur le
Président Retailleau
on est sur un point dur parce que on est
parti des 413 milliards c'est le
discours de Mont-de-Marsan du président
de la République et le problème c'est
les 13 milliards sur les 13 milliards il
y en a 5,9 qui ont été sécurisés le
président Cambon l'a très bien dit et on
bute sur cette virgule 4 milliards c'est
cette divers monsieur le ministre c'est
pas pour mettre du matériel neuf dans
des hangars rouillés c'est d'abord pour
accroître l'activité opérationnelle de
nos armées première chose deuxième chose
si j'essaie parce que le raisonnement
était pas simple parce qu'il était pas
clair mais si j'essaie de rentrer dans
votre raisonnement report de charge
et en même temps marche frictionnelle un
report de charge chers collègues c'est
une dépense différée une marge
frictionnelle
je me trompe pas c'est un crédit qui ne
sera pas consommé nous sommes d'accord
le problème c'est que vous monsieur le
ministre vous comptez aussi bien le
report de charge donc la dépense
différée et la marche frictionnelle donc
le crédit non consommé comme des
ressources et donc par conséquent le
compte ne peut pas y être nous ne sommes
pas 4003 nous sommes sans doute un peu
plus de 400 mais certainement pas 400
trade chers collègues et j'invite à ce
que le Sénat tienne bon sur cette base
là il en va de l'avenir de nos soldats
de nos armées de leur fidélisation et
comme le disait à l'instant de miguelage
l'image du surbooking est comme un aveu
vous avez un avion de 400 places vous
surbooké à 413 places vous n'en ferez
rentrer de toute façon que 400 points
final donc notre point de vue est bien
le bon j'ajoute encore une fois ma
chemise vraiment croyez moi je suis
sincère d'ailleurs vous le savez je ne
vous prends pas en traître ces
discussions nous l'avons eu ensemble
donc j'essaie d'être dans la vie
publique et privé voilà droit donc ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que les
choses pour nous nous les avons
inscrites à l'annuler à l'année à 1 de
l'article 3 nous restons dans
l'enveloppe de 413 milliards voilà merci
monsieur le Président Cambon
je suis désolé pour nos collègues on
reste un petit peu sur ce sujet mais il
est absolument central dans notre
discussion je crois effectivement comme
le président Retailleau vient de vient
de l'évoquer que tout provient de la
présentation certes excessivement
communicante des 413 milliards prenons
le problème à l'envers vous auriez dit
400 milliards budgétés plus 5 milliards
6 de recettes extra budgétaires mais qui
sont bien identifiés les sénatrices et
les sénateurs sont des gens raisonnables
ils peuvent imaginer que des ressources
extrabes budgétaires bien identifiées
même si on peut évoquer tel ou tel
incertitude ou telle ou telle
prévision un peu généreuse en tous les
cas ça nous paraissait il lui fallut
dire 405 milliards très bien au moins
405 milliards c'était déjà un effort
considérable c'était plus de 100
milliards par rapport à la précédente
LPM et ce sont ces 7 milliards qui dès
le premier jour dans les commentaires de
la presse dans les commentaires que l'on
entend ici ou là créer des suspicions
alors vous nous parlez des reports de
charge moi je vais citer de 2008 votre
professeur madame Alliot-Marie en 2008
il y a 28% de report de charge on croit
que le budget la nualité la nuitée
budgétaire défense va exploser les
industriels dont vous nous dites qu'ils
tirent des bénéfices de cette affaire
ils étaient au bord de la dépression en
se disant mais quand va-t-on être payé
parce que c'est facile de dire vous
serez payer l'année prochaine et on
versera des intérêts mais ce que veut un
industriel c'est généralement quand il y
va matériel c'est de recevoir le
paiement qui correspond et donc je pense
que le report de charge on peut
l'imaginer mais pas dans un pas pour un
tel niveau 7 milliards c'est énorme et
les marches frictionnelles tout autant
il fallait dans ce cas ne pas en parler
et dire la loi de programmation
militaire c'est 400 milliards + 5
milliards de recettes
identifiées à ce moment-là bon alors
Cédric Perrin aurait dit peut-être plus
d'autorédie peut-être moins après chacun
se fait son avis mais tout le monde
aurait dit il y a un effort vraiment
substantiel de plus de 100 milliards et
ce serait très bien passé et toute la
polémique qui dure est liée à ces
recettes budgétaire si vous êtes dans
ici il y a des gens qui ont été des mers
des conseillers départementaux vous
l'avez dans le votre argent vous l'avez
dans le budget vous l'avez pas si vous
l'avez pas vous pouvez dire
effectivement il va m'arriver je vais
gagner à la loterie puis je vais mettre
cet argent pour le dépenser mais tel
n'est pas le sens me semble-t-il d'une
loi de programmation militaire qui doit
justement bien
identifier la possibilité de faire ses
dépenses parce que comme ça vient d'être
rappelé c'est pas pour faire c'est pas
pour demander des recettes en plus pour
le plaisir de vous mettre en difficulté
c'est parce que le diagnostic de la
commission mais il peut être partagé par
l'ensemble de cette assemblée c'est que
c'est maintenant qu'il faut de
l'entraînement quand des pilotes
arrivent même pas à faire 160 heures
d'entraînement alors que les normes
c'est 220 heures autant et du coup il
fiche le camp ils vont s'engager chez
Transavia c'est ça le sujet c'est-à-dire
il faut fidéliser non mais je prends
exprès des exemples qui permettent de
bien identifier les choses on veut plus
d'entraînement plus d'entraînement pour
notre armée terre notamment on a cité
l'exemple des régiments des des
des de nos des Leclerc etc donc je crois
que il y a un véritable problème dont
nous sommes prêts à discuter puisqu'on a
jusqu'à la CMP mais je pense qu'il faut
que le Sénat reste sur cette position
s'il n'y a pas une prévision budgétaire
stricte ou en tous les cas bien
comprises il n'y a pas de possibilité de
dire qu'on dépensera 413 milliards et ça
reste de la communication si monsieur le
ministre
merci beaucoup pour revenir sur la pub
personnel que le président Retailleau
est évoqué je je connais votre sincérité
donc évidemment jamais je me permettrai
de la remettre en question après au
global j'ai parfois le sentiment quand
même que donner le point au président de
la République de l'augmentation des
crédits militaires et parfois quelque
chose qui est difficile et donc on
cherche à moins dire l'effort je ne
parle pas de vous mais c'est arrivé dans
un autre
mais je pensais un hémicycle que j'ai
quitté il y a peu de temps sur la même
loi mais je le dis bah
5 choses
avec la même bonne foi
et je veux vraiment que ça soit compris
1 vous examinez un projet de loi dans
lequel dans le rapport annexé vous avez
413 milliards d'euros de besoins
militaires
je vais me reprendre d'ailleurs je
reviendrai ça sera mon point 4 ce n'est
plus vrai nous sommes en train
d'examiner un texte dans lequel nous
avons un besoin militaire désormais de
416,2 milliards d'euros puisque la copie
a été alourdi personne n'y est revenue
sur ce point mais c'est une réalité qui
va falloir peut-être corriger un moment
donné ou alors ça veut dire que le Sénat
propose des évictions et des
renoncements sur certaines autres cibles
que vous n'avez pas amendées mais ça je
le dis parce que sinon l'ensemble de la
cohérence tombe ah oui 3,2 milliards
d'euros de dépenses supplémentaires
depuis le début de l'adoption des
amendements en commission deuxième des
choses
de tomber pas sur le mot surbooking
comme pour emballer rapidement le débat
monsieur le sénateur de neige il y a
toujours eu des marges frictionnelles
donc toutes les lois de programmation
militaires mal m'en a pris j'ai voulu
par transparence les montrer au
Parlement je dois bien vous avouer que
je le regrette un peu néanmoins je pense
quand même que c'est une bonne chose que
de le montrer et qu'est-ce qui se passe
il y a deux manières de faire dans le
dans ce dans cette programmation et
c'est pas qu'on espère les retard mais
sur 7 ans il est inévitable que vous
aurez un certain nombre de retards et
donc ils sont intégrés déjà dans la
copie c'est pour ça que lorsque vous
passez de 400-407 ça ne vient pas les
écraser mais ça les additionne et dans
cette marche fictionnelle soit vous
l'intégrez en disant je prends 103 pour
avoir 100
ce que d'ailleurs les sénateurs ou le
sénateur de votre groupe ancien ministre
de la Défense a pu faire et je
revendique cette méthode c'est une bonne
méthode soit c'est ce que vous proposez
une fine en disant pour avoir 97 je
prends 100
je vois pas en quoi le ministère des
armées gagnant dans cette affaire donc
je revendique de nouveau cette marche
exceptionnelle elles sont bonnes pour le
fonctionnement du ministère sur les
rapports de charge la différence avec
Michel et le mari en 2008 pardon d'être
cruel de revenir à 2008 c'est que du
report de charge sur des crédits en
euros constants avec une diminution
forte du format des armées c'est sûr que
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle pour les
industriels quand vous avez des reports
de charge sur beaucoup de commandes pour
nos propres besoins mais aussi
malheureusement hélas pour l'Ukraine
forcément vous êtes dans un niveau de de
perspective pour la base industrie les
technologique de défense dans lequel des
reports de charge trouve un intérêt
différent d'ailleurs pour avoir suivi de
près vos débats jamais les industriels
ne se plaignent des report de charge
pour être très clair aujourd'hui et pour
cause bah oui pour cause si je veux dire
contraire je veux dire c'est bien sujet
qui pose pas de problème pour eux c'est
bien ça d'ailleurs au passage si j'étais
sénateur dans mon opposition comme
dirait l'autre je dirais mais enfin
quels sont les coûts des reports de
charges le cas échéant bon et ben je
vous réponds aussi puisque je ne suis
pas mon propre posant mais comme
l'inflation est forte et bah au fond les
gains que vous donnent ces report de
charge sont bien supérieurs au coût de
ces records de charge vis-à-vis des
industriels et ça je voulais écrire je
l'ai écrit au sénateur delène j'en ai
fait la démonstration après si une pour
pas se juger on finit par écraser des
dispositifs qui sont bons pour le
ministère des armées je le regretterai
mais promis je ne le ferai plus dans le
Figaro quatrième chose je vais revenir
quand même j'ai 3,2 milliards d'euros de
dépassement au moment où on se parle
et cela puisque vous êtes attentif à
dernier point quand même sur les marches
fonctionnelles parce que c'est le
président Laurent a raison quand même de
pointer ça si vous n'intégrez pas les
marges frictionnelles dans votre
programmation vous entraînez en plus des
risques d'éviction soit sur d'autres
politiques publiques dans l'état c'est
ce que vous avez dit monsieur le
Président dans un autre argumentaire
mais néanmoins techniquement c'est pas
faux soit évidemment au sein même des
éléments de programme pour le ministère
des armées je voulais aussi rajouter cet
argument là qui me semble important
aussi dans la logique où vous allez
regarder la LPFP à venir non là on a 3,2
milliards d'euros de dépenses
supplémentaires je le redis qui sont non
documentés pour le coup par le Sénat qui
fait que on n'est pas à 400 407 ou 413
toute façon on est à
416,2 et que pour le coup puisque j'ai
entendu le président Retailleau au nom
de sa majorité dire que il ne fallait
pas aller au delà de 413 ça veut donc
dire qu'il y a des renoncements quelque
part dans la copie et évidemment je si
on rajoute du matériel dans les 413 la
définition dépasse 413 ça il y a pas de
c'est facile à comprendre pour le coup
le raisonnement est un placable si vous
rajoutez du MCO ce qui n'est pas le même
débat que les marches les marches
étaient de dire monsieur le ministre
conversation que nous avons eu tous les
deux il y a des choses ça nous semble
urgente de le faire dès maintenant dès
en 24 et pas attendre 27 28 mais c'était
dans les 413 ou dans les 400 comme vous
voulez d'ailleurs là c'est autre chose
vous rajoutez des cibles nouvelles et
des choses nouvelles vous les glissez
pas de 27 30 vers 24 27 sur 24 30 vous
rajoutez des choses et ça pour le coup
c'est pas documenté c'est pas financé et
si vous restez dans l'enveloppe globale
ça veut donc dire qu'il y a des
renoncements à 3,2 milliards d'euros
c'est beaucoup d'argent et donc ça veut
dire qu'il y a des renoncements quelque
part en tout cas moi je merci pour les
changes de débat parce que ce que j'ai
entendu surtout c'est que personne ne
veut aller au-delà des 413 milliards
d'euros ça je pense que c'est de la
clarté du débat et l'honnêteté me
commande de le dire ça veut dire que je
renvoie à d'autres à d'autres cadres et
d'autres formats le fait de pouvoir nous
accorder
merci alors je vais mettre au voile
amendement du Gouvernement numéro 282
avec un avis défavorable de la
commission qui est pour
qui contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté
la maman 148
monsieur le Président Laurent
oui merci madame la Présidente c'est un
amendement qui vise à supprimer le
membre de phrases qui a été rajouté dans
le travail parlementaire visant à dire
que les chiffres que nous qui sont
maintenant sécurisés par la nouvelle
trajectoire adoptée s'entendent comme un
minimum
d'abord les chiffres sont sécurisés
par par le nouveau tableau adopté
ces chiffres en plus si on veut vraiment
avoir une idée de l'ensemble de nos
dépenses militaires ils sont supérieures
puisque on sait qu'il y a une série de
dépenses notamment les dépenses pour
l'Ukraine et d'autres je ne refais pas
la liste qui a fait le ministre lui-même
tout à l'heure qui ne rentre pas dans
cette enveloppe donc on est au-delà de
413 milliards de dépenses militaires et
on rajoute cette phrase alors que déjà
on sécurise tout je pense que cette
phrase introduit une ambiguïté je sais
que certains la lisent en disant
on continue de sécuriser au minimum mais
on peut la lire autrement c'est de dire
que c'est un minimum donc qui est appelé
à augmenter encore au delà de ces
chiffres donc nous nous sommes pour
supprimer cette ambiguïté et supprimer
cette phrase qui n'ajoute rien en fait
une fois que les chiffres sont sécurisés
par le tableau
renouvellement adopté
merci la vie de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
c'est un alinéa que la ligne A que cet
amendement propose de supprimer avait
été en fait introduit par le rapporteur
de la commission de la Défense de
l'Assemblée nationale il s'agit de dire
que la trajectoire de ressources
budgétaires est un minimum c'est le
ministre vous avez affirmé à plusieurs
fois devant les commissions que les
marches proposées étaient démarches
planchées et non démarche plafond et
compte tenu de de nos finances et
dispositions n'est peut-être pas très
opérante mais étant donné à la fois les
incertitudes et le jeu de l'inflation
sur la situation géostratégique la
précision qui a été introduite nous
sommes opportunes donc c'est un avis
défavorable merci la vie du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre même raisonnement
donc même avis défavorable merci alors
je mets aux voix donc l'amendement 148
qui a reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui contre qui s'abstient n'est donc pas
adopté le 191 monsieur le Président
Gontard
oui merci madame la Présidente c'est à
maman un amendement qui vise à garantir
le financement de la LPM par le recours
à des nouvelles recettes les écologistes
sont favorables aux projections
budgétaires des 4 lois de programmation
examinées par le Parlement ces deux
dernières années l'aide publique au
développement le ministère de
l'Intérieur ministère de la Justice qui
permettent de renforcer les moyens des
pouvoirs publics de donner de la
visibilité de programmer des
investissements pluriels et d'une
manière générale nous sommes favorables
au renforcement des moyens de la
puissance publique en d'autres
circonstances les écologistes
profondément pacifistes n'aurait sans
doute pas approuvé une augmentation
aussi massive des moyens de la défense
mais la démocratie est plus que jamais
menacée à l'aise de l'Europe et le
soutien d'effectible à l'Ukraine
justifie à nos yeux les efforts
militaires auxquels la nation conscient
toutefois avec cette amendement nous
voulons nous assurer que les dépenses
financières conséquentes prévues par la
loi de programmation militaire n’empiète
pas sur celle des autres missions du
budget général telles que l'éducation
par exemple la santé le risque est en
effet que la conjugaison des
programmations budgétaire ambitieuse
s'agissant notamment des missions
regayen de l'État également du
dogmatisme de votre gouvernement qui
refuse de faire contribuer les plus
aisés à l'effort collectif ainsi que
votre promesse irréaliste et discutable
de rétablir le déficit budgétaire sous
les 3 % entraîne mécaniquement le risque
de faire peser l'effort financier
proposer par la LPM sur les autres
missions du budget de l'État je l'ai dit
l'éducation nationale la santé la
transition écologique la culture on vous
préciserez peut-être en tout cas ce
n'est pas acceptable donc le présent
amendement vise donc à garantir un
financement d'alpm assuré par de
nouvelles recettes et non des transferts
de crédit susceptibles d'affaiblir des
services publics déjà moins de riz ou
d'amputer nos ambitions en matière de
transition écologique merci si la vie de
la commission monsieur le Président
c'est un raisonnement que l'on ne peut
pas reprendre à notre compte puisque il
tente à opposer l'effort de défense aux
autres missions du budget de l'État je
rappelle que l'effort de défense est
moins de 2% du budget les dépenses
sociales c'est plus de 30%. donc bien
évidemment c'est un un raisonnement qui
ne correspond pas à notre approche de
ces sujets par ailleurs l'effort de
défense est un formidable accélérateur
économique un euro investi dans
l'industrie de défense rapporte deux
fois plus à l'économie au bout de 10 ans
donc bien évidemment c'est un avis
défavorable merci la vie du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
oui mais la présidente alors il y a
l'aspect politique que le président
Cambon évidemment signal c'est moi j'ai
toujours vigilant quand on peut opposer
vous l'avez pas fait mais comme parfois
sur les réseaux sociaux ça se dit je
pense qu'au poser les différents pans
des budgets de l'État les uns aux autres
sont toujours très délicat et très
difficiles donc je pense que ça c'est
limite de ça pose la question plus
globale de la soutenabilité je veux pas
revenir à la LPFP etc mais il est
évident que la trajectoire initiale que
nous proposons elle ne crée pas d'effet
d'évictions sur les autres programmes
puisqu'elle a été imaginée et conçue
comme tel avec Bercy ça c'est une
réalité d'où les longs débats sur 413 et
suivant je recommence pas parce que pour
le coup là inévitablement un moment
donné on commence à avoir une difficulté
en tout cas la vie défavorable merci
alors oui monsieur le président
Cambon c'est vrai que j'ai déjà pas
opposé les budgets au contraire je m'en
suis bien préservé j'ai même dit que le
budget et les prévisions qui étaient là
étaient importantes et dans le contexte
actuel au contraire je demandais juste
et cet amendement précise justement où
est-ce qu'en gros on va prendre cet
argent et effectivement ça aura
forcément un impact sur l'ensemble des
autres budgets et c'est toute la
problématique de fait d'avoir un budget
dédié sur sur la question de de
de l'armée on a quand même cette
problématique là et ça pousse quand même
avec le nombre de budgets qui se qui se
qui s'interpose comme ça et qui
s'additionnent au bout du compte quels
seront les autres les autres secteurs
qui seront qui seront impactés ou alors
qu'elle ressource le ministre peut nous
apporter pour justement apporter ces
nouvelles ressources merci monsieur le
président Laurent
je partage que vient de dire le
président Gontard et j'ajoute que si on
voulait pas
organiser mettre en opposition des
budgets comme vous le dites monsieur le
ministre encore faudrait-il ne pas
réserver la la programmation budgétaire
à certains budgets et pas à d'autres je
prends deux exemples très rapidement
nous avons eu ici en débat pendant de
longs mois une loi dite de programmation
de l'aide au développement dont la
grande caractéristique et qu'elle n'a
jamais été une loi de programmation
budgétaire puisque toute programmation
budgétaire sérieuse nous a été refusé
dans ce débat budgétaire donc là par
exemple nous ne savons pas comment ça va
évoluer deuxième exemple dans tout un
tas de domaines de la transition
écologique j'en prends un par exemple il
n'y aura aucune reconquête du
ferroviaire français dans le domaine du
fret sans une réelle programmation
budgétaire il n'y en a aucune
donc si on veut lever ce type de débat
et sécuriser les choses à ce moment là
il faut avoir une vision de la
programmation budgétaire qui ne se
réduisent pas uniquement au ministère de
l'intérieur et au ministère de la
Défense il faut avoir un débat plus
large sur ces questions et à ce
moment-là on pourra discuter des
arbitrages réels qui sont rendus mais là
en vérité les budgets ne sont pas à
égalité même quand il s'agit de budget
stratégique et même quand il s'agit de
budget qui ont besoin de la
programmation sur longue période merci
alors je mets aux voix donc l'amendement
191 qui a reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission du gouvernement qui est pour
[Musique]
qui est contre qui s'abstient n'est donc
pas adopté la maman 192 président compta
oui merci Madame madame la Présidente
l'amendement que nous proposons a été
travaillé avec I can France qui est le
relais national de la campagne
internationale pour abolir les avenues
nucléaires et ils vise à s'assurer que
l'investissement nucléaire ne dépasse
pas 13% du montant global de la LPM la
dissuasion nucléaire représente selon
les mots exprimés à plusieurs reprises
par Monsieur le Ministre 13% du montant
global de la VPN soit 53,69 milliards
d'euros nulle part pourtant dans cette
loi ce montant ou même ce pourcentage
est inscrit contrairement aux dépenses
liées à de très nombreux programmes
d'armements et contrairement aux
précédentes LPM il est donc nécessaire
de maîtriser les dépenses en matière de
dissuasion nucléaire pour ne pas
pénaliser les autres programmes et
objectifs de cet LPM certes notre modèle
d'armée repose largement sur la
dissuasion qui peut contribuer à
préserver la stabilité et à éviter les
conflits majeurs entre les États dotés
de l'arme nucléaire et peut constituer
un devenir essentiel de garantir la
sécurité nationale et de protéger les
intérêts vitaux mais d'une les formes en
matière de dissuasion grève largement
d'autres efforts notamment en matière de
renforcement des moyens de notre armée
de terre et contribue largement à
l'échantillonnage de notre armée et de
deux la dissuasion ne nous évite pas un
conflit militaire indirect avec une
puissance nucléaire et nous nous permet
pas de faire l'économie d'un armement
conventionnel enfin sur investissement
ce domaine pourrait nous conduire au
delà de la doctrine de street suffisance
et créer une spirale dangereuse de
prolifération nucléaires pour toutes ces
raisons il nous apparaît indispensables
de plafonner les dépenses relatives à la
dissuasion nucléaire pour s'assurer
qu'elle respecte les engagements de la
France et pour ne pas qu'elle morde sur
le reste des besoins de l'armée merci
Merci la vie de la commission monsieur
le président
oui madame la Présidente la Commission a
reconnu l'intention de cet amendement à
savoir que nous cherchons toujours à
essayer d'en savoir plus et c'est vrai
que une enveloppe de 50 milliards sur la
diffusion nucléaire méritent des
éclaircissements et on aura l'occasion
dans le travail de la commission de
revenir sur ce point néanmoins la
rédaction de cet amendement n'est pas
acceptable et je dirais qu'une par les
temps que nous connaissons de très
grandes menaces tous ceux qui concerne à
la fois le renouvellement et la
modernisation de notre dissuasion
nucléaire qui est notre assurance ultime
ne peut pas être négligée donc c'est un
avis défavorable merci la vie du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
la présidente
avis avis défavorable Pierre Messmer
avait une très jolie formule il disait à
propos de la dissuasion nucléaire dans
les dans les textes financiers
économiques et financiers enfin
budgétaire que à certains secrets
militaires il fallait aussi il y a
adjoindre une forme de discrétion
budgétaire et de fait pour désormais de
l'autre côté de la barrière la
structuration même des crédits il y a la
dissuasion dise des choses sur notre
dissuasion voilà et que donner des
détails c'est donner des informations et
des signalement stratégiques importants
aux autres compétiteurs donc c'est pas
un problème de manque de volonté
typiquement sur la cette édit par le
sénateur sigleety sur la disponibilité
du matériel pour le coup j'ai accepté de
faire le bouger enfin il y a des il y a
des enjeux sur lequel on peut donner un
peu plus de transparence sur la
dissuasion nucléaire très vite vous
donner à voir au contenu des programmes
de modernisation et en fonction de ce
que vous dites sur le degré de
modernisation de la dissuasion vous
envoyez donc aussi autant donner
directement un certain nombre de secrets
à nos compétiteurs c'est ce qui explique
qu'est-ce qu'il y a monsieur le
président
c'est un peu sans fin c'est que dans mes
V c'est un peu c'est un peu comme les
marges frictionnelles je veux dire c'est
que en fait on se demande pourquoi il
faut répondre aux questions parce que
effectivement en commission plusieurs
fois vous m'avez dit on veut savoir quel
est le la part global de la dissuasion
j'ai regardé ce qui était communicable
au Parlement je dis 13 %. après vous
faites un amendement pour expliquer il
faut caper à 13%. je vous explique que
non déjà pour des raisons de détails
mais je pourrais aussi dire et si ça
faisait 15% en quoi ça serait grave
après on revient à des bas de fond vous
êtes contre la dissuasion ce que je
respecte mais que je ne partage pas mais
à la question pourquoi je donne un
chiffre parce que vous m'avez posé la
question pour vous aussi vous dire
pourquoi vous avez repris mon chiffre
dans un amendement pour le café donc
voilà donc c'est un peu sans fin c'est
la poule et l'oeuf en tout cas la
dissuasion c'est la clé de voûte de
notre défense pour la protection de nos
intérêts vitaux et comme vous le savez
je l'ai déjà dit plusieurs fois en
commission mais je le redis ici vous
avez tous les 20 ou 25 ans des efforts
de modernisation qui sont un cap sur par
exemple les scénélo ou sur les avions ou
sur l'hémicides ou sur d'autres aspects
plus critiques qui tiennent évidemment
aux têtes et que donc par définition
vous avez des pics et ça je m'en étais
aussi expliqué par rapport à la
chronique budgétaire qui fait que la
dissuasion va connaître énormément de
modernisation entre 202829 jusqu'en 2035
je forme le vœu que les majorités qui
viendront et les présidents de la
République qui suivront défendront la
dissuasion nucléaire mais c'est parce
qu'en fait entre le moment où vous
décidez un programme à le moment il
s'est exécute en crédit de paiement ça
prend du temps aujourd'hui on vit sous
l'empire de la dissuasion globalement
décidée par Jacques Chirac et Nicolas
Sarkozy vous avez une énergie très très
forte évidemment que vous retrouvez
aussi sur les crédits de paiement ça
aussi évidemment c'est quelque chose qui
est propre à ce modèle
si alors je mets au voile la maman 192
car si on avait défavorable de la
commission du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abscine n'est pas
adopté l'amendement 237 du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre défendu merci la
vie de la commission monsieur le
président
la commission aura un avis défavorable
parce que cet amendement vise par ces
explications laconiques a supprimé un
excellent amendement du sénateur de
neige rapporteur de la commission des
finances qui vise les cas où la France
procède à des sessions de matériel
militaire à d'autres pays c'est-à-dire
des exportations du matériel d'occasion
la moindre des choses c'est quand on
cède un Rafale à la Grèce ou à la
Croatie ou à d'autres pays car nous
sommes toujours plutôt favorable il
convient de le remplacer et pour le
remplacer si vous vous touchez le
produit d'un
d'une vente d'occasion vous êtes obligé
de compléter pour acheter un avion neuf
on rachète pas d'avion d'occasion donc
je pense que l'amendement de Dominique
de Lège était un amendement tout à fait
et important et donc c'est un avis
défavorable monsieur le ministre à votre
amendement
merci alors je mets aux voix donc la
maman du gouvernement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission c'est la
maman 237 qui est pour
[Musique]
qui est contre qui s'abstient ils ne
vont pas adopter deux amendements
discussion commune le 149 monsieur le
Président Laurent
oui c'est c'est un amendement d'appel et
je vais m'adresser en particulier à
Monsieur le Ministre enfin Madame la
Ministre
puisque
la Commission a pris la peine de
préciser dans cette phrase rajoutée que
le LPM de financerait en aucun cas le
service national universel c'est la
première fois dans le texte qui les
mention du service national universel et
on retrouvera cette référence à
différents endroits du texte donc la
question moi que je pose parce qu'on a
eu des versions différentes la dernière
on date c'est l'interview que vous avez
donné dans le Figaro mais on a eu
plusieurs versions de de ce dispositif
et on comprend toujours pas
explicitement quel est son lien à la loi
de programmation militaire puisqu'il
figure à plusieurs endroits de ce texte
donc y a-t-il un lien entre le SNU et la
loi de programmation militaire lequel
parce que sinon on ne voit pas pourquoi
ce dispositif figure d'une manière ou
d'une autre dans le projet de loi quel
est ce dispositif est-ce que c'est un
dispositif de formation militaire qui va
s'adresser puisque c'est le dernier
dispositif annoncé à des jeunes de 14
ans pendant des séjours de 12 jours sur
le ton scolaire si ça n'est pas le cas
quel est son rapport avec la loi de
programmation militaire nous on veut
comprendre quel est la nature de ce
dispositif et je le répète pas seulement
en général mais dans son lien la loi de
programmation militaire sinon toute
référence au SMIC n'a rien à y faire
d'autant plus que la Commission dit la
LPM ne financera en aucun cas le SMU
si l'amendement 194 monsieur le
Président Gontard
oui merci merci madame la Présidente
c'est un peu dans le même dans le même
sens que le précédent amendement en fait
il s'agit tout simplement sur la
question du s&u effectivement il est
dans cette dans cette LPM et il apparaît
dans cette MPM et donc il nous
paraissait important de préciser puisque
l'objectif de sa demande est de
clarifier que le service national
universel et c'est nul restera
entièrement volontaire puisqu'il ne peut
être établi sous la contrainte car le
lien entre la nation et l'armée doit
continuer à être fondé sur un engagement
volontaire et donc pour lever tout
ambiguïté il est proposé de le dénommer
service national volontaire ça nous
paraît aussi aller dans le sens de même
la ministre qui nous avait indiqué que
le service national universel était
justement volontaire et donc comme il
est inscrit dans ce texte autant
préciser justement son caractère
volontaire merci la vie de la commission
monsieur le président
merci madame la Présidente c'est une
position constante de la Commission de
d'avoir dit depuis que le projet de SMU
madame la ministre et
a été lancé par le Président de la
République avec l'intérêt que le Sénat
peut bien évidemment y porter mais c'est
une position constante de la Commission
de dire que le Séni ne peut pas être
financé par la LPM je prends juste un
exemple si nous étions en année pleine
pour une classe d'âge c'est une dépense
de l'ordre de 3 milliards alors vous
voyez ce les conséquences que ça oui ce
serait on profite du ministre pour dire
que c'est en plus des 413 et donc vous
voyez les conséquences que ça aurait
donc bien évidemment c'est un avis
défavorable sur l'amendement de notre
collègue Pierre Laurent et bien
évidemment en ce qui concerne la
transformation du s&i en service
volontaire là aussi la loi de
programmation militaire n'est absolument
pas le bon véhicule pour débat du SMU
nous sommes à la disposition de la
ministre je suis heureux qu'elle soit
ici pour l'entendre et pour développer
ce projet merci si la vie du
gouvernement madame la ministre
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs pour faire peut-être un
point assez assez global sur le service
national aujourd'hui le projet est
totalement volontaire il a si demain la
modalité devait échanger évidemment ce
serait avec une proposition avec un
projet de loi qui devrait être débattu
évidemment dans nos deux champs et ce
serait évidemment votre décision
définitive qui devrait l'emporter pour
apporter de la clarté sur le nouveau
projet du service national universel sur
le temps scolaire ça c'est le projet
volontaire d'établissement et de classe
qui choisissent la forme d'engagement en
réalité notion pédagogique plus que
nécessaire pourquoi le service national
universel est cité dans le rapport
annexé et dans la forme du texte
présenté par le gouvernement pour une
raison toute simple il y a dans le
service national universel dans son ADN
même et dans son projet pédagogique le
renforcement du civisme de la
citoyenneté et en réalité également du
lien armé jeunesse puisque il y a la
journée défense et mémoire qui est
évidemment vous le savez est présenté
par un certain nombre
bien de nos armées puisque elle est
portée par la direction la dsnj la
direction de la jeunesse du ministère
des armées au-delà de ça évidemment il y
a la phase 2 puisque nous parlions de
exclusivement du séjour de cohésion donc
la phase d'internat et le séjour
volontaire d'engagement déjà une qu'elle
a mis son intérêt général peut prendre
plusieurs formes et vont vous en
connaissez un certain nombre les cadets
de la gendarmerie les escadrières
jeunesse ou encore des engagements
civils ça peut être service civique
engagement associatif dans un EHPAD et
bien divers engagements donc pour
répondre à votre à votre question la
réalité c'est que non il n'y a pas de
financement dans le cadre de l'alpm et
nous sommes totalement en phase avec le
président de la commission qui a apporté
une réponse extrêmement claire donc
c'est un avis défavorable pour les
amendements 149 monsieur le Président et
le lendemain monsieur le Président en
194 également je vous remercie merci
alors je mets où voir la maman
monsieur le Président Laurent
oui moi je voudrais m'associer aux
remarques de mes deux collègues qui
d'ailleurs disent que ce sont des
amendements d'appel moi je suis
totalement d'accord avec ce qu'il y a
dans l'article 3 Linéa 10 dans la
première partie c'est à dire ce qui a
répété le président Cambon tout à
l'heure les ressources ne comprennent
pas le financement du SNU mais ce que je
ne comprends plus c'est que ce nu il est
inscrit va disposer de financement adoc
mais qu'est-ce que c'est des
financements Haddock ou allez vous
trouver ces financements Haddock autre
chose excusez moi vous allez dire que je
pose des budgets de l'État j'espère que
ce ne sont pas des financements liés à
l'éducation nationale parce que ça avait
été évoqué et parce que madame la
ministre vous propose diverses et variés
à travers la presse nous inquiète et ne
nous rassure pas du tout sur ce point
vous parlez de prendre le SNU sur le
temps scolaire vous dites que les
voyages scolaires vont être assimilés
enfin c'est à peu près la même chose
donc je n'oppose pas des budgets je veux
simplement vous dire notre inquiétude et
vous dire aussi que ce passage en force
du SNU sans faire le bilan de quoi que
ce soit nous exaspère beaucoup
merci ce président Laurent
oui madame la ministre je crois que sur
cette question là sur la question du
lien défense jeunesse ou armée je pense
qu'il y a besoin d'un débat national
sérieux et d'ailleurs nous avons fait
adopter un amendement qui a été retenu
par la commission pour appeler à se
débat national mais les formules
actuelles qui sont avancées les unes
après les autres du SNU ne répondent pas
à cette question
ils ne peuvent pas s'adresser qu'à des
jeunes de 14 ans en seconde donc nous
avons besoin d'un débat national sur
cette question qui n'existe pas pour le
moment et ça fait des années que la
question est posée la question du
volontariat elle est toujours pas réglée
j'entends ce que vous dites mais c'est
le volontariat de qui des établissements
de professeurs avec leur classe des
élèves et de leurs parents parce que là
on parle d'enfants de 14 ans seconde
13 14 15 ans donc qui est volontaire
c'est ça n'est pas clair et comme en
plus il s'agit d'une période de 12 jours
sur ton scolaire donc on parle pas un
problème mineur dont le parcours
scolaire des enfants surtout à cet
âge-là donc je pense que le dispositif
n'est pas clair le débat nécessaire sur
le lien armé jeunesse fait défaut et il
faudra l'ouvrir un jour de manière
sérieuse et transparente avec le pays et
enfin je retiens je vais retirer mon
amendement parce que je suis d'accord
avec la formule c'était je l'ai bien
amendement d'appel là LPM n'a pas à
financer en l'état le sénu mais ça veut
dire que nous devrons retirer le SMU par
exemple quand il figure dans des
énumérations plus tard dans la loi au
même titre que la réserve opérationnelle
monsieur le Président Quentin
rapidement parce que je rejoins tout ce
qui a été dit mais c'est vrai que sur le
SMU en fait beaucoup de choses sont
dites et on vous écoute sur à la fois
son organisation le fait qu'il soit
volontaire etc mais rien n'est jamais
inscrit quoi et donc un moment donné il
va peut-être falloir préciser là on vous
en donne l'occasion en tout cas sur
l'aspect volontaire vous nous dites que
c'est volontaire s'il est inscrit dans
la loi et ben autant inscrire très
clairement qu'il est volontaire et puis
c'est vrai que si on nous dit qu'il ne
doit pas être dans la loi ben en tout
cas il faut le faire il faut le qu'on
puisse l'enlever en tout cas de toutes
les mentions qui peuvent être faites
tout au long de ce texte
merci alors même la ministre
de manière extrêmement courte madame la
Présidente mais pour rapporter un
certain nombre d'échanges qu'on a eu
évidemment ce débat n'a pas vocation à
avoir lieu au sein de la MPM donc
j'aimerais pas alourdir les débats mais
le SMU c'est de 15 à 17 ans en réalité
ce sur la base du volontariat
aujourd'hui c'est demain ça devait
évoluer il y aurait un débat un débat
parlementaire et madame la sénatrice
pour vous rassurer le budget du service
national universel est un budget
autonome qui ne touche ni à l'éducation
nationale ni aux armées c'est un budget
qui est une ligne qui s'appelle la 163
c'est jeunesse vit associative et en
réalité son budget a toujours été
autonome puisque j'étais moi-même
parlementaire quand il a été créé il en
avait la charge et j'avais une seule
inquiétude et tout à fait légitime
c'était que ça vienne piocher dans
d'autres budget que ça affaiblisse
d'autres projets jeunesse et c'est pour
ça qu'elle est sanctuarisée elle a
augmenté proportionnellement aux
engagements et peut-être monsieur le
sénateur pour compléter aujourd'hui le
FC nu continue à évoluer bien sûr mais
il a trouvé une il a trouvé en tout cas
une aspiration au sein de la jeunesse il
y a plus de
au journalistes qui a la parole et pour
conclure et revenir sur les propos
essentiels aujourd'hui le projet n'a pas
vocation à être débattu dans la LPM mais
je suis à la disposition des
parlementaires évidemment et des
sénateurs pour entrer dans le détail du
projet merci alors je mets au voile à
mon nom 194 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient et donc
pas adopté je me vois l'article 3 qui
est pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
il est donc adopté alors après l'article
3 la maman 69 monsieur Ferro
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre si nous avons choisi avec des
idées avec collègues du groupe
socialiste de présenter cet amendement
c'est parce que dans la discussion de
cette LPM il nous paraît pas possible de
discuter exclusivement des dépenses sans
aborder aussi la question des recettes
on le voit d'ailleurs bien avec
l'ensemble du débat que nous venons
d'avoir sur report de charge marge
frictionnelle la réalité des moyens que
nous nous donnons et donc nous avons
proposé un amendement pour lever des
recettes supplémentaires afin de
financer les investissements et les
dépenses considérables dont nous avons
besoin pour protéger notre pays nos
compatriotes dans les années qui
viennent qui concerne la loi de
programmation militaire
je pense qu'il y a d'ailleurs là un vrai
parallèle avec les travaux notamment de
Jean pisaniferi sur le financement de la
transition énergétique comment nous le
finançons comment nous faisons en sorte
que ce financement pèse de manière
raisonnable sur la dette publique et
comment nous faisons aussi en sorte que
le financement soit socialement juste
donc notre amendement propose de lever
une taxe sur les placements d'assurance
vie à partir d'un certain montant pour
que cela ne pèse pas sur la classe
moyenne ou les classes populaires si le
dispositif d'ailleurs ne paraît pas
pertinent à la majorité sénatoriale ou
au gouvernement il en existe d'autres
possibles sur le patrimoine on s'est
battu en vain ces derniers mois pour une
taxe sur les super profits nous sommes
toujours favorables à des dispositifs de
cette nature qui permettent de trouver
les financements nécessaires aux
considérable dépenses publiques dont
nous avons besoin donc voilà nous avons
voulu élargir le débat sur la LPM avec
cet amendement en parlant des recettes
nécessaires pour les dépenses j'espère
que cela pourra intéresser notre
assemblée quelques minutes mais si la
vie de la commission monsieur le
président
un président c'est amendement vit
simplement à augmenter la pression
fiscale sur les ménages avec cette
originalité c'est que
il n'est pas précisé qu'il finance les
dépenses militaires donc c'est
évidemment un avis tout à fait négatif
merci Merci la vie du gouvernement oui
maman 69 qui a reçu un avis défavorable
de la commission du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre ah non bah je l'ai
mis au voix donc voilà donc qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient pas adopté
à l'article 4
prise de parole de Monsieur Olivier si
le golotti merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
à ce stade de la discussion nous
souhaitons apporter deux points de
précision avant l'examen de l'article 4
et les deux amendements du Gouvernement
nous avons modifié en commission cet
article pour prévoir que le financement
interministériel des surcoulis aux Opel
c'est aux missions intérieures ne
souffriraient pas d'exception liées je
cite à des circonstances exceptionnelles
qui justifierait que la mission défense
contribue au-delà de sa proportion dans
le budget de l'État cela ne nous paraît
pas judicieux monsieur le ministre vous
demander un effort qui est volontiers
qualifié d'historique à la nation cet
effort est là pour préparer notre trou
nos troupes à la haute intensité
l'engagement majeur et nous nous sommes
pas pouvoir constituer une poire pour la
soif dans un contexte budgétaire déjà
dégradé et enfin deuxième point à cet
article nous avons également ajouté la
présentation annuelle par vous monsieur
le ministre du bilan détaillé des
opaques et des missions intérieures il
sera à leur temps de débattre de la
contribution de la mission des forces à
leur financement merci
Alain passons à l'amendement 238
monsieur le ministre un rendement du
gouvernement
monsieur le ministre la Présidente je me
je suis distrait
le 200 les deux sont défendus
j'insisterai bien volontiers sur le 238
pour essayer de comprendre sur le je
reviens pas sur circonstances
exceptionnelles bon sur les JO
c'est un amendement au fond qui est un
amendement d'appel pour comprendre ce
que vous avez vous souhaitez faire en
commission vous avez structure
évidemment OPEX et ce qu'on appelle
missent mission intérieure mission
intérieure évidemment sentinelle on y
reviendra plus tard évidemment harpie
parce qu'on est sur le territoire
national et c'est pas une mission facile
pour les forces armées on pourra
peut-être aussi revenir et puis il y a
une mission ponctuelle spécifique aux
forces armées que sont les Jeux
Olympiques sur des missions qui sont
celles des forces armées postures
permanente de sûreté de l'espace aérien
lutte antidrone
renforcement de la sécurité dans sa zone
d'emprises militaires dans Paris pour
soulager les forces de sécurité
intérieure mais on reste dans le cadre
et donc la copie que je vous avais
présenté initialement
évidemment prenez en compte ce que le
ministère des armées doit pour le voler
Jo ce qui a été documenté par les États
majeurs et qui nous semble sincère bon
ça a été raboté un tout petit peu en
commission je sais pas pour quelle
raison parce que au fond il y a deux cas
de figure
enfin non il y a deux éléments
d'information vous devez avoir en tête
le premier c'est que le chiffre tel
qu'il est présenté il correspond bien à
des missions
militaire sur les jeux sur les Jeux
Olympiques c'est logique de faire de
mettre une provision pour se faire et si
votre inquiétude c'est que il y ait un
dépassement on est bien dans ce tableau
dans les logiques de provision et donc
c'est évidemment le financement
interministériel qui serait sollicité si
nous devions aller au-delà de la
provision donc j'insiste peut-être plus
lourdement même si je sais que les avis
des commissions sont déjà fait mais sur
le 238 je trouve qu'on fera je prône le
rétablissement de l'approvision initiale
parce qu'en terme de sincérité
budgétaire elle correspond à l'argent
qui documenté par les États majeurs pour
réussir l'émission qui lui sont
dévoluées forces armées sur sur les Jeux
Olympiques 239 y être revenu il est
défendu
la vie de la commission monsieur le
Président sur ces deux amendements
alors j'ai pas le suivant sur le 238
donc c'est un amendement qui revient sur
un amendement qui avait été voté par nos
collègues socialistes qui a été adopté
en commission et qui prévoyait que le
financement des Jeux Olympiques était
exclusivement inter-ministériel et ne
s'imputait donc pas la provision
annuelle au titre des opaques et demi
sainte c'est ce qui avait conduit
monsieur le ministre à la diminution de
50 millions d'euros alors nous sommes
tout à fait d'accord pour que les
militaires participent à la sécurisation
du territoire pendant les Jeux
Olympiques on est un petit peu moins
d'accord pour que le ministère des
armées finance intégralement cette
dépense et donc c'est pour ça que nous
donnons un avis défavorable
merci Monsieur le Ministre
avis défavorable aussi sur le 239 sur la
réintroduction de la possibilité d'une
contribution plus que proportionnelle de
la mission défense pour les mêmes
raisons donc il n'est pas question de
revenir sur le principe qu'on a évoqué à
vie défavorable c'est Monsieur le
Ministre
merci beaucoup
vous voyez ma tristesse à ne pas avoir
été avec vous en commission pour pouvoir
expliquer les choses et
m'écouter n'est pas une infraction à la
séparation des pouvoirs
non sur le 238 de bonne foi les
provisions telles qu'elles sont
construites sont bien sur les missions
militaires
lutte anthydrone le boulot des forces
armées l'armée de l'air en espèces la
posture permanente dans le ciel qu'on va
durcir pendant les JO et donc il est
logique on sera en insécurité budgétaire
si on ne l'avait voilà et là vous l'avez
diminué un peu mais en fait
mais en fait c'est normal de prendre sur
la la part qui correspond à l'activité
des forces en temps normal enfin ça ne
viendrait pas à l'esprit de rebasculer
l'ensemble de la posture permanente de
sûreté du ciel on a terminé ministériel
enfin le système fonctionne parce que
Président le Président
il est il est fait telle sorte ou si ça
dépasse ça part en interministériel mais
il faut quand même que ça corresponde à
la réalité des missions militaires
telles qu'on les imagine en tout cas là
je trouve qu'on va abîmer un tout petit
peu la structure des choses pour 2024 je
tiens vraiment à le dire pour le pour le
Sénat en revanche je m'engage
si on devait avoir des éléments qui
seraient nouveau dans ce qu'on
demanderait aux forces armées pour les
JO bon il est évident que là on repart
en interministériel voilà je voulais
quand même le dire parce que c'est un
point important me semble-t-il
merci alors je vais mettre aux voix donc
la maman 238 du gouvernement qui a reçu
un avis défavorable de la commission qui
est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient n'est pas
adopté la maman 239 même avis même vote
n'est pas adopté je me vois l'article 4
qui est pour contre qui s'abstient il
est donc adopté à l'article 5 Monsieur
Olivier sigolottier a demandé la parole
monsieur le ministre nous allons abordé
dans cet article 5 la problématique des
carburants opérationnels nous avons
souhaité ajouter le même type de
garantie si les cours chutent en dessous
de 85 dollars par baril pour utiliser
comme hypothèse de construction de la
LPM et bien la mission défense ne sera
pas ponctionnée ceci vise à ce que un
pari à la baisse ne soit pas tenté en
gestion et qu'un signe ni gel ni mis en
réserve ne puisse être décidée sur la
base d'une prévision baissière des cours
des énergies opérationnelles les Accous
qui seraient générés n'iraient
grandement à notre sens à la bonne
exécution de cet LPM merci
merci alors l'amendement 195 président
merci merci madame la Présidente le but
de cet amendement est un rapport soit
remis au Parlement sur les moyens pour
nos armées de limiter leur consommation
de carburant plus précisément nous
souhaitons que ce rapport inclus
également une réflexion sur les
possibilités de rationalisation de
l'utilisation de carburant en dehors de
théâtre d'opération mais aussi sur les
possibilités d'éco-conception
d'équipement militaires notamment des
véhicules l'armée possède beaucoup
d'équipements très polluants si elle a
longtemps été exemptée de tout objectif
de réduction de ses émissions de gaz à
effet de serre il lui faut aujourd'hui
prendre sa part et les forces nationales
lorsque le contexte le permet mais c'est
aussi un enjeu stratégique important la
dépendance de nos armées aux énergies
fossiles posent des questions sur la
capacité de nos armées à opérer
efficacement la fluctuation des prix du
pétrole et d'autres énergies fossiles
ainsi que leur déclin prévisible à long
terme est une problématique qu'il faut à
tout prix prendre au sérieux de plus
c'est un enjeu financier nos armées
dépensent près d'un milliard d'euros en
carburant soit aujourd'hui plus de 2% de
leur budget la volatilité des prix du
carburant faisant peser une incertitude
sur notamment la trajectoire même de
cette LPM
fasse donc à un environnement
énergétique en constante évolution il
nous faut renforcer la durabilité et la
résilience de nos armées il ne s'agit
pas ici de contraindre les militaires
sur un terrain d'opération mais bien de
réfléchir à une nouvelle génération de
véhicules qui en ne consommant pas ou
peu de carburant fossile pour y gagner
en durée de route de vol et en capacité
opérationnelle il s'agit aussi sans
contrainte excessive de porter une
attention accrue à l'économie des
carburants en dehors des théâtres
d'opération qu'il s'agisse de la
logistique militaire ou des exercices
donc nécessaire de réaffirmer notre
engagement pour la transition vers une
économie à faible émission de carbone
non seulement pour lutter contre le
changement climatique mais également
pour garantir notre sécurité et notre
dépendance
merci la vie de la commission monsieur
le président
madame la Présidente
carbone de nos activités militaires va
dans le bon sens et ce rapport viendra
effectivement étayer les travaux qui
sont faits dans ce domaine la commission
ennemi a émis un avis favorable merci la
vie du gouvernement monsieur le ministre
oui merci elles font et la forme sur le
fond évidemment ça va dans le bon sens
sur la forme demander aux armées de
produire un rapport uniquement sur ce
sujet
me semble
on va dire non mais c'est un petit juste
sauf que vous avez par ailleurs adopté
sous le contrôle du président évidemment
le bilan annuel LPM à l'article 8 donc
moi ce que je vous propose c'est juste
une affaire de méthode c'est que on peut
obliger ça je m'y engage à ce que dans
le rapport annuel de la LPM on est tout
un chapitre du manque documenté sur cet
aspect des choses mais un rapport dédié
une fois de plus je trouve que c'est
peut-être une affaire de forme voilà
donc ça retrait contre cet engagement
sinon sagesse mais je pense qu'il faut
quand même faire preuve de briefter dans
la manière de construire cette affaire
merci monsieur le Président Quentin
je comprends et je pense quand même que
c'est pas c'est pas un petit morceau
quoi enfin c'est quand même quelque
chose d'assez important et qui prend
l'ensemble parce qu'il y a à la fois la
question de la décarbonation les types
de carburant il y a enfin voilà je sais
que c'est quand même pas donc si on peut
enfin si vous ne donnez l'engagement
effectivement que cet aspect là sera
vraiment pris
mais pas j'irai par le petit bout de la
lorniette et qu'on aura une réflexion
sur l'ensemble je peux retirer
l'amendement et je fais confiance à
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre
merci beaucoup non un je m'y engage pour
la mémoire des débats et de je vous
l'écris comme ça ça cadre les choses et
de fait je trouve ça bien de le traiter
dans le tout parce que ce qui fera aussi
avancer le combat c'est de le traiter
comme étant un paramètre naturel basé ce
clé dans la politique publique quand on
le fait à côté il y a toujours un tout
petit bon mais compris donc merci en
tout cas pour le retrait et on se
regarde
si alors je mets au voile
5 contre qui s'abstient il est donc
adopté à l'article 6 j'ai une demande de
prise de parole de Monsieur Marc Lamini
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre madame la ministre sur le
président de la commission
défense à faire étrangères à force
armées en saluant aussi tout le travail
qui était fait sur sur ce texte
important puisque l'objectif 400
milliards d'euros en loi de
programmation militaire et concernant ce
cet article 6 je soussierai aussi à mes
propos ma collègue sénatrice des
Ardennes elle se Joseph puisque j'irai
dans les Ardennes on a la chance vous
connaissez bien notre département
monsieur le ministre la chance d'avoir
un régiment le troisième régiment du
génie et là cet article 6 ce sont les
moyens humains les effectifs donc je
crois que c'est réellement
particulièrement
important et malheureusement on regrette
souvent que beaucoup de départements
n'ont plus de militaires dans les
départements et l'évolution des
effectifs ça serait l'objectif 275
000 E équivalentons plein en 2030 alors
la question c'est quand même comment
susciter l'évocations même si on annonce
vous annoncé monsieur le ministre une
progression forte de la réserve
opérationnelle comment susciter
l'évocation les difficultés de
recrutement c'est souvent rappelé et
puis aussi il y a certes la JDC le
service national universel bon non nous
accueillons les Ardennes régulièrement
je dirais des jeunes de 15-17 ans le
service militaire volontaire puis aussi
le lien avec l'éducation nationale les
classes défenses dans des collèges dans
des lycées donc il y a un lien aussi
important alors pour et puis aussi
fidéliser les effectifs parce que je
dirais dont le SMU est aussi beaucoup de
dévouement aussi des encadrants et je
crois que c'est mérite d'être souligné
mais c'est surtout fidéliser et susciter
l'évocations voilà je voterai cet
article merci
Monsieur Philippe Folliot
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre monsieur le
Président de la Commission mes chers
collègues effectivement cet article 6
concerne la manœuvre RH et c'est un
élément important
nous avons quelques-uns à avoir en
mémoire un temps finalement pas si
lointain ou le seul ministère des de la
défense supportée les deux tiers des
baisses défectifs dans la fonction
publique et donc le fait qu'il y ait une
augmentation nette telle que proposer
dans le cadre de cet article est un
élément éminemment positif dont nous ne
pouvons que nous réjouir monsieur le
ministre je voulais juste vous
interpeller sur pour être en logique et
en cohérence avec ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure même si vous êtes difficile je
le comprends bien de nous dire à ce
stade là
où vont aller des augmentations
d'effectifs mais est-ce que en fait il y
aura un objectif en ce qui vous en ce
qui vous concerne d'essayer de faire de
telles sortes par rapport à ces enjeux
que j'ai développé tout à l'heure
relativement force de souveraineté qu'il
puisse y avoir un élément
j'allais dire un petit peu
d'orientation dans ce cadre-là et puis
ensuite le deuxième point et comme l'a
dit notre collègue tout à l'heure fort
justement il y a un autre élément qui
est très important par rapport à la
manœuvre effectif c'est la fidélisation
donc de celles et ceux qui font le choix
des armes parce que nous sommes dans une
situation qui dans certains bassins
d'emploi se rapprochent du plein emploi
et que donc dans ce cadre-là il est
important de faire de telle sorte que
celles et ceux qui signent un contrat
puissent rester rester le plus longtemps
possible tout au moins le temps où ils
auront profité de leur formation et
c'est un enjeu qui est un enjeu
important pour la suite merci alors nous
passons à l'amendement 98 de même
Carlotti
oui merci madame la Présidente le projet
de loi de programmation militaire vient
interrompre la trajectoire
d'augmentation des effectifs qui étaient
prévus par la précédente loi de
programmation militaire elle réduit le
nombre d'embauches en 2024 et en 2025
puisque on est passé de 1500
équivalentes en plein prévus pour 2024
demi 1500 prévues pour 2005 et on passe
à 700 en 2024 et 700 en 2025 donc je
trouve que la montée en puissance des
recrutements est repoussée là aussi un
peu comme pour la trajectoire financière
et repousser à la fin du mandat du
Président de la République
est-ce qu'on a le droit d'attendre
autant de temps et de perdre autant de
temps pour doter nos armées d'effectifs
suffisants afin de faire face comme vous
le dites souvent à une guerre de haute
intensité je sais pas on perd beaucoup
de temps dans le recrutement des
effectifs c'est pourquoi nous proposons
dans cet amendement de reprendre les
objectifs de l'ancienne loi de
programmation militaire et puis de lycée
le reste merci Merci la vie de la
Commission monsieur le président
l'occasion de dire tout à l'heure que
déjà le ministère n'arrivait pas à
recruter les 1500 postes budgétaires qui
étaient proposés donc il nous apparaît
que cette trajectoire
n'est pas cohérente avec la trajectoire
budgétaire qui a été adoptée par la
commission et donc il nous semble que là
cette nouvelle trajectoire pour la
création de poste dans le périmètre du
ministère des armées n'est pas la bonne
donc je propose un avis défavorable
merci la vie du gouvernement monsieur
ministre oui merci beaucoup madame la
présente Madame la Ministre alors je
pense que c'est un amendement d'appel en
tant que tel parce que par définition la
structuration du tableau fait que ce
n'est pas évidemment complètement
faisable je pense que l'urgence si un
combat s'était dit par le sénateur
follow si un combat amené c'est
évidemment la fidélisation on est à
grande ministère employeur et dans
lequel le solde entre ceux qui rentrent
et ceux qui sortent doit rester
évidemment un solde positif et ça
évidemment c'est pas tant l'attractivité
pour embaucher la capacité que la
capacité pardon à garder un certain
nombre de de personnels et de cible
particulière de personnel pardon de le
dire de manière un peu technique ça
m'amène à deux publics qui méritent à
mon avis attention assez particulière la
première c'est celle d'une sous-officier
qui constitue la structure quand même du
modèle d'armée et en fait on le voit
bien ou au fur et à mesure des années
les revalorisations du SMIC et du point
d'indice font qu'il y a eu un tassement
entre les sols de la troupe et
évidemment les premiers grades de
sous-officiers sergent ou second maître
sergent-chef et évidemment ce
déséquilibre on le retrouve dans
l'ensemble de la pyramide des graves
donc ça c'est le premier combat si j'ose
dire ramener vous avez pris des
amendements en commission qui vont dans
le bon sens qui correspond cet
engagement mais je pense que pour celles
et ceux qui suivent les débats avant de
parler des chiffres et nos armées
regardent le débat je pense qu'il faut
renvoyer ce message important le
deuxième type de métier sur lequel il y
a un enjeu important en matière de
fidélisation et d'ouverture de poste
nouveau là on commence à avoir la
jonction des deux c'est évidemment ce
sont pardon évidemment les métiers
autour du cyber qui sont évidemment des
métiers particulièrement chassés par le
privé et ça vaut aussi d'ailleurs pour
la DGSE dans lequel vous avez de jeunes
gens qui commencent leur formation qui
sont embauchées au sein des structures
aux différentes structures cyber du
ministère et qui au bout de 4 ou 5 ans
pour des enjeux de fidélisation
salariale mais pas que aussi de mobilité
enfin bref le problème est complexe sont
amenés malheureusement à quitter le
ministère donc ça c'est les deux les
deux combats vraiment absolument clé de
la réussite de la programmation
militaire ensuite il y a une courbe
effectivement d'augmentation de TP alors
c'est là où on peut pas comparer les LPM
entre elles parce qu'après tout jadis il
s'agissait d'augmenter des structures de
combat quand je dis déjà 10 il y a
longtemps par exemple sur des régiments
d'infanterie aujourd'hui on le voit bien
c'est pas tellement sur l'infanterie de
mêlée que nous sommes attendus que
plutôt justement sur la guerre
électronique ou sur la transformation
cyber de l'armée de terre donc on a une
trajectoire qui correspond aussi aux
besoins des employeurs
et à la réalité aussi des capacités
embaucher et surtout la capacité à
fidéliser parce que sinon on remplira
jamais évidemment les différents
objectifs qui sont à signer de part de
par la loi donc avis défavorable vous
demande de retrait plutôt parce que
c'est un amendement d'appel et je pense
qu'au fond dans le bilan annuel de la
LPM à chaque fois devant vous
j'essaierai de justifier chaque année en
tout cas où mon successeur ma successeur
comment on est arrivé à remplir
l'objectif ou pourquoi on n'y est pas
arrivé et surtout vous donner des
éléments analytiques parce qu'au fond le
remplir sur la troupe c'est pas la même
chose que de le remplir sur la DGSE qui
n'est même pas la même chose que de le
remplir sur les fonctions de soutien et
ça aussi j'aimerais pour les réserves
mais c'est l'approche qualitative
évidemment de la scie pardon d'avoir été
long mais ça me semblait important
d'être complet d'un ministre oui même
Carlotti
oui merci Monsieur le Ministre oui je
vais retirer cet amendement et sachez
que sur les deux combats que vous avez
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure nous
avons déposé des amendements notamment
sur l'ami des bornes pour l'évolution
indiciaire parce que je crois que c'est
très important et deuxièmement sur les
questions de la fidélisation beaucoup de
notre commission répondent à ce souci et
donc je réponds moi au président Cambon
et je lui dis qu'effectivement au regard
de la trajectoire que nous avons adopté
à l'article 3 donc je retire cet
amendement merci alors troisième
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 197 monsieur le
Président compta
oui merci merci madame la Présidente
très rapidement il s'agit d'un
amendement comme le précédent au sujet
du SMU puisqu'on retrouve la mention et
l'indication du s&u dans cet article 6
et donc on voulait ajouter la notion de
volontaire
voilà bon je pense que je peux je vais
le retirer puisqu'on a eu on a eu les
débats tout à l'heure mais en tout cas
voilà il y a un quand même un problème
de cohérence puisque le seu on le
retrouve tout au long de ce texte merci
alors le 97 madame Carlotti
alors le 97 il est en deux parties sur
la linea 4 j'avais fait une
reformulation que je trouvais plus
claire plus incisive pour dire
qu'effectivement mais on l'a dit tout à
l'heure que la loi de programmation
militaire ne prévoit pas la mobilisation
des ressources humaines des armées pour
la mise en place du disciple positif du
sanu je c'est dedans donc moi je
préférais ma formule mais c'est adopté
par la commission me convient très bien
et deuxièmement je remercie le ministre
de s'associer et de soutenir
l'amendement socialiste à la Line et à 6
puisque vous proposez comme moi la
suppression de la référence au SL
merci
et la maman 240 monsieur le ministre
oui de fait il est il est défendu alors
l'amendement du Gouvernement supprime
tout simplement votre amendement
supprime et rajoute le fait que c'est
pas dedans donc ça revient à peu près
enfin on rajoute une phrase dans un ke
donc sagesse sur votre amendement
évidemment enfin je redonne juste la
lecture quand même pour le Sénat
sur les réserves à ses effectifs ça
voudra enfin l'augmentation des
effectifs des volontaires de la réserve
opérationnelle militaire et du service
national universel porté à 80000 en 2030
puis à 105000 etc donc ça je le redis
même s'il y a eu des velléités parfois
par certains services de mon ministère
de se dire que si jamais le SMU
peut-être que moi je ne rentre pas
là-dedans je donne mon engagement auprès
du Parlement le SNU n'est pas dans la
LPM
et il n'y a pas de lien entre le service
national universel et les augmentations
des cibles de réserve sauf évidemment à
ce que des jeunes d'eux-mêmes
volontaires au FC nu deviennent
volontairement réservistes mais ça ça
tombe tellement sous le sens qui a pas
besoin de le spécifier l'eau mouille et
le feu brûle bon donc vraiment je
défends cet amendement farouchement
parce que sans quoi ça veut dire qu'on
se retrouve avec le SCI dans la
programmation militaire c'est tout
l'inverse de ce qu'on se dit donc voilà
non mais je sais que les services sont
plus produire des choses
il y a un ministre dans un ministère et
c'est lui qui est responsable devant le
Parlement donc c'est la Constitution et
rien que la Constitution le essénu n'est
pas dans la loi de programmation
militaire et par définition il n'y a pas
de lien entre le SNU et les réserves en
tout cas moi je souhaite qu'il puisse y
avoir une clarification donc favorable
même à l'amendement même car le tissu du
gouvernement n'était pas adopté
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
président
alors le 197 a été retiré le 90 le 97
nous proposons un retrait puisque cet
amendement était satisfait par les
modifications qui a été apportées en
commission au projet de loi alors en ce
qui concerne l'amendement 240 monsieur
Miss effectivement nous nous sommes
basés dans un une proposition d'avis
défavorable sur le fait que votre
cabinet a écrit noir sur blanc qu'il
fallait rajouter pour bien comprendre le
chiffre de 80 000 15000 en 2030
comptabilisé dans les effectifs
d'augmentation de la réserve monter en
puissance des volontaires du sénu bon
alors vous nous apportez une précision
ça veut donc dire que vous engagez ici à
atteindre le chiffre de 80 000 sans les
effectifs du sénu c'est bien ce que l'on
doit comprendre auquel cas dans ce cas
là la vie de la commission est favorable
merci alors je mets aux voix la maman 97
qui a reçu une demande de retrait de la
Commission et un avis favorable du
Gouvernement et pas retirer même
Carlotti non donc je mets au bois qui
est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté je me
vois l'amendement du Gouvernement 240
qui a reçu un avis favorable à la
commission qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il est
donc adopté le 241 monsieur le ministre
un moment du gouvernement
oui madame la Présidente alors le
gouvernement aussi a le droit de faire
des amendements d'appel
je n'arrive pas à comprendre la
trajectoire telle qu'elle est proposée
par la Commission sur les réserves pour
plusieurs raisons enfin première
question déjà celles et ceux qui ont
introduit la disposition comment
l'avez-vous calculé sur quels
documentation et quel besoin en matière
de ressources parce que là on a une
division d'un objectif linéaire or pour
le coup je reste persuadé que le combat
pour les réserves c'est un combat qui
doit se mener c'est un combat qui sera
très car beaucoup d'aléas évidemment
parce que on n'est pas sur une politique
salariale classique la réserve c'est un
engagement individuel il y a une
géographie déjà des réservistes et puis
accessoirement
c'est pas complètement la même chose
entre officier et sous-officier et homme
durant que c'est pas complètement la
même chose entre Marine nationale armée
de terre armées de l'air que c'est pas
complètement la même chose entre
territoire d'outre-mer et l'Hexagone que
d'ailleurs si on avait une approche des
réserves d'un point de vue purement
militaire je pense qu'il faudrait
davantage regarder les priorités par
unité plutôt que par chiffre donne deux
exemples très concrets Délégation
Générale pour l'Armement évidemment
service de santé des armées sur lequel
le besoin en réserviste c'est très
important donc moi je questionne le
Sénat pourquoi on a cette chronique qui
déjeune semble pas réaliste pour être
complètement transparent et surtout
s'éloigne me semble-t-il des besoins
militaires mais j'ai besoin de le
comprendre deuxième des choses pourquoi
plus 25000
soit 65000 en tout c'est à dire en clair
on est à moins que l'ambition initiale
je vous rappelle que on est sur 80 000
autour de 80000 là aussi il faut enfin
c'est pas scolaire comme débat dans une
programmation autour de 80 000
réservistes en 2030 autour de 100000
c'est une idée du ratio qui compte c'est
ça qui est intéressant politiquement
dans le format d'armée on a 200 000
soldats d'actifs on a donc à terme
l'objectif d'avoir 100 000 réservistes
et c'est donc un modèle d'armée dans
lequel j'espère qu'un jour on pourra
dire nous avons 300 000 militaires dont
200 000 d'actifs et sans mille
réservistes c'est ça l'esprit mais vous
auriez droit de me dire mais pourquoi
pas 95 ou 105000 vous avez bien raison
de me le dire ça se trouve d'ailleurs ça
sera comme ça à la fin mais ce n'est pas
grave c'est le ratio qui compte en tout
cas là sur la chronique telle qu'elle
est proposée on a une chronique de
réserve qui est plus faible que ce que
le gouvernement avait proposé
et je ne comprends pas pourquoi au fond
il y a une proposition de réduire
l'ambition d'où l'amendement 241 porté
par le gouvernement pour revenir
évidemment à la chronique sachant que le
taux si à la rigueur vous souhaitez une
chronique
moi ce que j'avais demandé aux États
majeurs mais attention ça sera toujours
une chronique indicative et elle ne
serait être contraignante c'est pas une
chronique capacitaire pour acheter c'est
pas une chronique budgétaire pour avoir
des ressources on est sur une politique
fondamentalement humaine là je pense
qu'on serait détaché toute forme de
réalité de la vie des forces si on était
dans une prescription donc il faut que
ce soit un objectif mou bienveillant
parce que c'est sans quoi il sera pas
compris par les États majeurs et par les
forces si on devait être sur une
chronique telle que je l'imaginais avec
l'état major des armées on serait en
2024 autour de plus 4500 2025 9000 2026
14 1500 2027 22000 2028 29 50029 36000
et 2030 40 000 bon mais pour arriver au
40 000 de plus bon
je suis pas en commission c'est bien
dommage et non mais
je ne sais pas ce que a voulu faire le
Sénat en commission donc je pose la
question moi je peux je peux évidemment
sous amender si il y a une demande parce
que je veux montrer ma bonne volonté à
une
oui voilà j'allais dire une condition de
bon sens et que celles et ceux qui
regarderont la loi en 2029 ou 30 on sera
peut-être plus là de dire ne pas dire
aux états majors à ce moment-là vous
n'avez pas rempli de la cible etc parce
que ça doit rester quelque chose qui
crée une chronique avec la même
transparence j'ai demandé aussi à ce
qu'on commence à réfléchir à des
objectifs par territoire parce que quand
le délégué militaire départemental de la
vendait au hasard aura des objectifs ça
lui permettra évidemment d'être un peu
plus motivé pour arriver à les remplir
donc je pense que ces affaires de
chroniques peuvent être regardées de
différentes manières
merci la vie de la commission monsieur
le président
sur le ministre je vais vous expliquer
comment nous avons procédé alors
effectivement votre amendement vise à
supprimer cette trajectoire des hauts
annuelle des effectifs de la réserve
opérationnelle donc nous il nous
paraissait que ces objectifs étaient
trop floues puisqu'il y avait en fait
deux jalons de rendez-vous 2030 et 2035
c'est-à-dire 7 7 ans et 12 ans après le
vote de la Loire c'est quand même un
petit peu incomplet alors on a demandé
des précisions à vos services et j'ai
ici le texte de la commission qui
reprend intégralement ce que votre
équipe nous a donné 3500 qui viennent
7000 qui viennent 10.500 qui deviennent
14000 c'est c'est exactement j'ai
exactement le la communication d'Égypte
qui nous ont été fournies et en fait il
y a un rattrapage des fameux 15 villes
du essai nu qui ont disparu dans la
bataille donc on s'est vraiment basé sur
les renseignements que vous nous donnez
il y a un petit problème de méthodologie
c'est une réponse écrite que j'ai
alors si vous rectifiez les chiffres on
devient avoir notre position mais sinon
on donnait un avis défavorable parce que
on souhaite préciser cette montée en
puissance des effectifs de la réserve
opérationnelle merci monsieur le
ministre
une fois de plus
dans notre Constitution tous les
questionnaires ne remplir nos
remplaceront jamais le ministre je pense
que c'est important de le redire et là
tel qu'on a cette rédaction on a bien
une diminution de l'ambition donc je le
redis donc moi je suis prêt à déposer un
sous amendement ou un nouvel amendement
le problème c'est qu'il faut suspendre
j'imagine pour ça puisque il s'agit
quand même de produire un tableau
chiffré pardon
là ça fait un peu juste de fait après ça
peut aussi un engagement du ministre ici
à avec une chronique puisque de toute
façon dans une part aussi indicative
comme je le disais et donc je
enfin la mémoire des débats le
compte-rendu faisant foi le Parlement
est ainsi éclairé des objectifs que veut
remplir le Gouvernement en la matière
sachant qu'une fois de plus même le
jalon en 2030 2035 il est pas si grave
j'ai envie de dire le vrai sujet c'est
par armer par service et pourquoi pas
même par grade parce qu'au fond quand on
dit augmentation du nombre de
réservistes il y aura aussi une
réflexion sur le pyramidage des grades
si c'est une armée de ficide réserve la
belle affaire faudra aussi quand même
qu'on ait des sous-officiers qu'on ait
des hommes durant donc façon il y a
peut-être une approche globale après je
peux aussi si vous le souhaitez produire
ou imaginer un rapport aussi au
Parlement sur le les réserves ou dans le
cadre d'audition spécifique du ministre
venir présenter aussi la politique des
réserves en tout cas moi je me dévoile
pas parce que je suis transparent avec
vous pour réussir cet objectif je vais
avoir besoin de vous également parce que
c'est une affaire aussi humaine de
mobilisation de la Nation pour que les
gens s'engagent et donc ce n'est pas que
prescripteur ça doit être aussi un
élément de motivation
oui oui monsieur le Président je vous
donne la parole et de nous éclairer un
peu sur ce que vous souhaitez faire à ce
stade allez-y monsieur le président
comme on est très fâché que votre
cabinet nous donne des réponses qui sont
pas les vôtres donc je me réserve ça
pour la pour la CMP comme ça on va
s'expliquer d'ici là donc pour l'instant
on garde un avis défavorable j'entends
vos explications mais sincèrement dites
à votre cabinet de
contrôler les informations qui nous
donnent c'est difficile pour la
commission de travailler on vous a
déposé un questionnaire de 82 questions
justement pour éclairer le Sénat et si
les réponses sont pas les vôtres c'est
un peu compliqué donc rendez-vous à la
CMP sur cet amendement
monsieur le ministre la réserve c'est
quand même un élément fort de de la
politique que vous portez c'est pourquoi
il y a une affichage mais il faut des
objectifs vous disiez des objectifs mous
en tout cas des objectifs et donc nous
c'est ce qu'on a voulu faire dans le
travail de la commission c'est une pâte
de mettre un carcan vous disiez tout à
l'heure je vous ai écouté pas de Carcans
c'est pas un carcan c'est donner une
vision donner quelque chose donc moi je
s'il y avait eu la possibilité que vous
posiez un dimension en ce qui nous
concerne notre groupe l'aurait accepter
parce que à ce stade c'est compliqué de
voter favorablement votre nous ça sera
défavorable à moins que vous puissiez
faire un amendement mais j'ai écouté le
président combo
merci vous voulez reprendre la parole
monsieur le ministre
puisque nous sommes éclairés si
l'amendement de toute façon devait être
adopté il y aura une suppression pure et
simple de l'acronique ce qui pour la CMP
priverait me semble-t-il si je me trompe
pas une discussion puisque le tableau
disparaîtrait donc puisque nous
travaillons en bonne intelligence moi ce
que je vous propose c'est que je retiens
l'amendement du Gouvernement comme ça le
tableau reste en l'état il vous fait une
accroche pour travailler avec vos
collègues parlementaires et en revanche
on en reste pas assez de chronique de
chiffres on la complète peut-être aussi
qu'on peut légender le tableau pour
aussi rendre plus
décrire la politique publique de la
réserve grade service etc pour montrer
qu'on est sur une cible complètement
indicative et non pas prescriptive en
tout cas c'est le le veut que je forme
en le faisant comme ça donc amendement
retiré
si monsieur le ministre je vous redonne
tout de suite la parole pour défendre
votre amendement 292
oui les défendu madame la Présidente
peut-être pour éclairer le Sénat donc il
s'agit de de recompléter le la Linéa
il se trouve que c'est une souplesse que
vous avez supprimée en commission mais
qui fonctionne bien dans la vie
quotidienne du minarme avec avec Bercy
pour être très clair et que globalement
cette capacité à avoir de la souplesse
dans la gestion des ETP et globalement
très attendu des états majeurs pour être
très direct et que jusqu'à présent ça a
bien fonctionné avec avec
l'interministérielle se priver de cette
souplesse c'est nous renvoyer à la
rigidité de comment dire de
l'organisation des ETP et à mon avis ça
va pas dans le bon sens donc je pour le
ministère je recommande forme enfin
vraiment chaleureusement et fortement le
fait de revenir à la rédaction initiale
merci la vie de la commission monsieur
le président
je vous suggère monsieur le ministre de
convaincre d'abord le Conseil d'État
parce que sur cette alinéa que nous
avons supprimé dans son avis du 30 mars
2023 il a rendu un avis considérant que
ces alinéa était obscures et donc nous
l'avons supprimé donc nous l'avons
supprimé pour deux raisons d'abord parce
que ça portait normative n'est pas
établie par n'est pas établi par le
ministère et par ailleurs on considère
que les recrutements du ministère de la
Défense ne doivent dépendre que de vos
besoins opérationnels expriment par les
armées ce qui nous semble tout à fait
receva et qu'il est pas souhaitable de
les faire dépendre de la situation du
marché du travail donc à ce stade nous
rendons un avis défavorable merci
monsieur le ministre
il est peut-être obscur pour le Conseil
d'État mais il est bien utile pour les
armées donc puisque vous voulez défendre
le ministère des armées c'est ce que
vous m'avez dit plusieurs fois monsieur
le Président en commission c'est un
dispositif de souplesse qui aide les
employeurs militaires non pas douté
quand on parle de situation sur le
marché du travail c'est évidemment le
dumping dont je pouvais parler tout à
l'heure sur les métiers du cyber
d'aménager justement l'architecture des
postes parfois les systèmes de
rémunération donc là on est en train
pour le coup je ne reviendrai pas au
Figaro puisque je bamakop mais là on est
en train de créer une rigidité qui n'est
pas profitable aux armées françaises
donc je le redis avec la même chaleur et
la même engagement que le président
rotaïeu tout à l'heure on est en train
de priver le ministère des armées d'un
bon outil pour les armées même si vous
voulez faire plaisir aux conseils d'État
je le note donc je j'appelle
véritablement le Sénat à voter
l'amendement du Gouvernement non pas
parce qu'il viendrait du gouvernement
mais parce qu'il est bon pour les armées
je peux pas dire mieux merci même
Carlotti
monsieur le ministre encore un
amendement de souplesse encore une
rédaction souple non on veut pas faire
plaisir au Conseil d'État c'est vrai
qu'il est confus cet amendement nous on
a décidé au sein de la quête de ne pas
de ne pas l'accepter parce que il laisse
entendre que les recrutements des
ressources humaines se ferait en
fonction du marché du travail plutôt que
dans l'intérêt des armées et donc ça va
à l'encontre avec ce que vous avez dit
tout à l'heure et que nous défendons
ensemble c'est à dire la fidélisation
l'attractivité donc nous on a compris
comme ça ça veut dire qu'il est pas très
clair
merci alors monsieur le Président Cambon
j'entends bien j'entends bien vos
observations donc ce que je vous propose
c'est de rédiger cet amendement d'ici la
CMP on verra si notre position peut
évoluer mais pour l'instant je maintiens
la position de la Commission
merci monsieur le ministre
et là pour le coup je maintiens vraiment
l'amendement du Gouvernement parce que
c'est en fonction de la situation des
marchés du travail que le ministère des
armées a de la souplesse avec Bercy pour
pour discuter et adapter chaque année
les choses vous avez une programmation
militaire et derrière vous avez
évidemment des tensions qui peuvent
apparaître ici ou là soit par bassin
surtout par métier en fait c'est surtout
ça la finalité et qui permet l'employeur
militaire de garder au fond ces ETP et
de les redistribuer sur un autre besoin
et ça c'est vraiment le boulot des
majors généraux des trois armées la DGA
fonctionne un peu différemment et le
Service de santé des armes mais aussi et
en fait c'est sur la base de ce qui est
écrit là que le ministère des armées
peut le faire dans le dialogue avec
Bercy si c'est supprimé ça ne sera plus
possible et une fois de plus je le redis
parce que je ne prends personne en
retraite c'est vraiment pas une bonne
nouvelle pour le ministère des armées et
voyez même l'interministériel m'a
autorisé déposer l'amendement c'est dire
si c'est quand même quelque chose auquel
je tiens donc voilà je j'insiste je
pense qu'il faut adopter cet amendement
du Gouvernement pour le bien du
ministère des armées
merci alors je mets au voile à mon nom
292 du gouvernement qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission qui est
pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient mais donc
pas adopté je mets au voie l'article 6
qui est pour contre qui s'abstient il
est donc adopté à l'article 7 la maman
61 monsieur Bono
oui madame la Présidente
pour objectif de garantir la mise en
oeuvre de que la mise en oeuvre de la
programmation se fera dans le respect
des villes la dignité humaine et vise à
renforcer le principe éthique et les
droits fondamentaux qui doivent guider
toute action militaire dans le cadre de
cette loi quatre préjudice avéré causer
aux vieilles dignité humaine des
mécanismes de réparation appropriés
devront être mises en place mise en
place pardon pour assurer une protection
adéquate des personnes affectées
merci la vie de la commission monsieur
le président
dont on est évidemment très sensible à
la dimension éthique au respect du droit
international humanitaire et la France
se tient ses notions pour tout à fait
fondamentales mais cet amendement n'a
absolument pas sa place à l'article 7
puisque l'article 7 concerne les
conditions d'actualisation de la
programmation militaire donc je pense
que le plus simple c'est peut-être
retrait sans ça un avis défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre mais ma vie
monsieur Bono je le retire merci alors
deux amendements de discussion communes
le 242 monsieur le ministre pour le
gouvernement
oui merci ma présence c'est un moment
d'appel là aussi sur le livre blanc bon
au fond ni pour ni compte comme dirait
l'autre bien au contraire
je peux pas ne pas voir quand même que
les exercices des livres blancs et dans
la mémoire et dans l'impression
rétinienne des forces armées sur les
deux derniers exercices ce livre blanc
ont été quand même imaginés pour
malheureusement faire endosser
techniquement une légitimité qui
permettait derrière de diminuer les
crédits militaires c'est comme ça que
c'est véhicules sont du ministère des
armées et c'est une réalité bon
deuxième des choses est-ce qu'il faut à
l'avenir imaginer des commitologiques
qui permettent de réfléchir tous
ensemble la réponse est oui c'est un
temps fait mal un peu ouvert le débat
lors de la DG enfin la discussion
générale tout à l'heure là le président
comme on l'a dit jamais une PM n'a été
autant travaillé chacun l'a fait à sa
manière moi vraiment je vous le redis
mais l'ensemble des contributions des
parlementaires par les nombreux rapports
qui sont produits par les commissions
ont largement été intégrées ce que
d'ailleurs c'est trop souvent ce n'était
pas le cas dans le Livre blanc parce que
tel ou tel sing tank ou le bide
d'intérêt était parfois beaucoup plus
sonore et beaucoup plus vocal que un
rapport parlementaire non mais or si on
est honnête la loi se construit quand
même avec le Parlement et dans la
démocratie représentative c'est quand
même bien de commencer par là
vraiment et je pense que là pour le coup
c'était le PM elle puis ça sans le
nombre d'amendements déjà à l'Assemblée
au Sénat la manière dont on le fait
c'est bon et puis si j'ose dire monsieur
sénateur temal votre article premier
plus votre discussion générale vous avez
brossé globalement toutes les menaces il
y a que le mot Iran que vous n'avez pas
cité sinon tout
vaut déjà tous les livres blancs donc
moi je ne me battrai pas sur cet
amendement la différence du précédent
qui est vraiment une mauvaise nouvelle
pour le ministère des armées autant que
celui-ci je pense qu'il doit redéfinir
un cadre en revanche j'ai une conviction
je l'ai dit à la tribune il faut
davantage repartir des orientations
politiques des parlementaires moi je
préfère le président Laurent qui vient
avec ses convictions et assez home ce
que je reviendrai plus tard dans la dans
la discussion sur la discussion
nucléaire sur le temps je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vous mais ça me semble
bien mieux que d'aller parfois capter
ici ou là différents groupes d'intérêts
je le dis comme je le pense qui ont
parfois des intérêts à pousser un
certain nombre d'amendements ou de
préconisations dans un livre blanc et
pardon je m'arrêterai là mais je peux
refaire la chronique du dernier qui a
quand même montré aussi de sérieuses
limites et de sérieuses difficultés en
tout cas moi je suis favorable à ce
qu'on continue de réfléchir à une
méthodologie pour l'avenir ça ça
participe évidemment à la construction
de la loi merci l'amendement 76 monsieur
temal
discussion commune oui oui voilà merci
allez-y même
c'est autour ah d'accord merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre madame
la ministre bon c'est amendement visa
renforcer le dispositif prévu visant à
mettre en place une commission chargée
d'un livre blanc sur la défense et la
sécurité nationale et s'assurer que cet
engagement sera effectivement proposé
sera effectif en proposant que cette
commission devrait être mise en place
avant le 30 juin 2028 alors que la LPM
qui succédera à la LPM 2024 2030 devra
être votée dans le courant de l'année
2029 alors pour rappel quand même un
livre blanc est chargé monsieur le
ministre de définir une stratégie
globale aussi de défense et de sécurité
c'est également l'occasion de donner une
certaine visibilité nécessaire à
l'ensemble chargés de notre sécurité
allant de ceux qui bien évidemment
produisent les matériels militaires à
ceux qui les utilisent c'est à dire nos
militaires en passant par celles et ceux
qui votent les budgets c'est-à-dire les
parlementaires en fait pour nous c'est
autant le document qui est important
puisqu'il sert de référence pour définir
des objectifs et une vision stratégique
dont nous avons besoin que l'exercice de
concertation qui a quand même
cruellement manqué au texte que nous
examinons je ne partage pas d'ailleurs
forcément votre avis que le sol
l'objectif d'un Livre Blanc serait de
limiter les le budget alors vous l'avez
compris nous sommes attachés à la
concertation au travail approfondie et
sérieux de réflexion qui pour un sujet
aussi régalien que celui de la Défense
nationale demande je crois un engagement
de toutes et de tous il va de notre
sécurité et de la paix à laquelle nous
sommes
à laquelle nous inspirons voilà donc le
Sénat entend jouer pleinement son rôle
dans cette exercice de concertation que
le Livre Blanc propose je remercie merci
monsieur le Président la vie de la
Commission
oui c'est amendement qui a été déposé
par nos collègues du groupe socialiste
c'est un petit peu le résultat de la
frustration que nous avons ressenti lors
de la préparation de cet LPM où il nous
a été communiquée une revue stratégique
qui a été rédigée excessivement
rapidement et qui n'a pas véritablement
associé le Parlement à ça à sa
conception comme ça avait été le cas
précédemment donc
nous soutenons nous soutenons cette
demande c'est de toute façon c'est pour
la prochaine LPM si on sait que si aux
alentours de 2028 on a encore le temps
d'y réfléchir et bien évidemment le
second amendement nous donnons un avis
favorable puisque il faudra constituer
la commission préparatoire à ce livre
blanc donc avis défavorable sur
l'amendement du Gouvernement et
favorable sur l'amendement du groupe
seisme merci monsieur le ministre
alors monsieur le Président Laurent vous
aviez demandé la parole
oui je crois que ce débat sur le livre
blanc il témoigne
de ce que j'ai essayé moi-même de dire
dans la question préalable quel que soit
les débats sur le fond mais une très
grande frustration partagée du Parlement
sur la préparation stratégique de la LPM
et je pense que quoi qu'on dise les uns
et les autres ici
ce manque de conception partagée
nous allons le ressentir au fur et à
mesure des évolutions désormais
extrêmement rapides de la situation
internationale et des gens et des enjeux
de défense donc je pense que le texte
actuel amendé par la commission renvoie
encore très loin ce travail donc moi je
vais soutenir l'amendement
socialiste parce que au moins il se
donne une perspective plus rapprochée
parce que ce travail est indispensable
il n'a pas été mené dans la préparation
de cette LPM il restera indispensable et
le repousser à la fin de cette LPM je
pense c'est trop tard nous n'avons pas
eu de débat sur l'actualisation du LPM
nous avons raté la préparation de
celle-là
se dire qu'on va rediscuter de tout ça
dans 7 ans c'est trop loin à la vitesse
à laquelle évoluer les choses donc il
faut des échéances plus sérieuses et
plus rapide donc on l'État avec toute la
frustration ça signifie pour moi et pour
mon groupe mais on votera quand même
l'amendement socialiste parce que c'est
celui qui nous rapproche le plus d'un
travail collectif et national absolument
indispensable
merci à la prison monsieur ministre vous
évoquez la question de livre blanc et du
passé j'ai envie de vous dire que je
pensais qu'avec le Nouveau Monde il y
aurait justement avec la même chose
mieux mais ça c'est voilà mais après la
réalité c'est que moi je ne vois pas en
quoi en niveau banc serait un problème
je pense que c'est vous l'avez dit la
façon d'associer l'ensemble des
parlementaires mais je voudrais élargir
un peu l'espace du débat parce que
d'abord ce serait bien d'avoir les
parlementaires le Parlement dedans mais
globalement la question des Français
même plus largement puisque et on le
voit d'ailleurs sur la question en
Ukraine on voit bien que la population
qui a emmenée se sent aussi concernés
par sa propre sécurité peut être associé
et c'est vrai qu'en France
assez peu le Parlement déjà mais encore
moins les Français nous avons un débat
dans notre pays sur les questions de
défense et donc moi je pense qu'à un
moment donné je dis pas que on n'a pas
d'amendement en l'espèce à ce stade mais
peut-être qu'il faudra aussi dans la
prochaine phase s'il devait avoir une
nouvelle loi de programmation militaire
poste celle que nous sommes en train de
voter je vois que la question de
l'Association des Français plus
largement non me semble essentiel parce
que si on veut encore une fois que la
question la défense soit partagée autant
que les Français soient aussi associés
en amont et puis il y a je crois que
vous avez su vous même d'ailleurs par le
passé faire des grands débats ou autre
on pourrait imaginer différentes
formules je crois que c'est un des
sujets qui sera quand même devant nous
malgré tout mais après c'était LPM
mais c'est le ministre
oui merci beaucoup ma présence je pense
que livre blanc est associé les Français
à la rigueur on peut disjoindre la le
débat moi je suis complètement convaincu
qu'il faut davantage associer notre
population
je dirais même plus les élites aussi
puisque je l'ai suffisamment dit ici au
micro
aux pupites enfin la tribune
pardonnez-moi quand on voit un certain
nombre de commentateurs qui place la
France dans la même position que
l'Ukraine en disant bah vous voyez on
peut tenir uniquement un front de 80 km
pendant 15 jours etc ça veut dire qu'on
a quand même des élites qui sur des
plateaux de télévision n'ont absolument
rien compris à ce que notre modèle
l'armée
sont-ils des élus de la question est
posée donc par définition il est clair
que je suis pas certain que pour moi
livre blanc ça correspond à deux
exercices normés normés
qui d'ailleurs n'associait pas la
population sur les honnêtes non mais je
donc quand on emploie le mot livre blanc
désormais vous n'échapperez pas au fait
que une partie de notre écosystème
politique ou militaire renverra aux
exercices du passé
non mais vous diriez que à un moment
qu'il faille imaginer des débats avec la
nation mais je sors de cette séquence et
Ukraine et même sur ce que vous avez
fait avec le bon débat sur l'Afrique que
nous avons eu ou au fond mais pourquoi
nos militaires sont morts c'est que
c'était quoi barkhane à quoi ça sert
avec etc et même si je peux me permettre
madame la sénatrice tout à l'heure j'ai
quand même un peu Bondy sur sur mon banc
lorsque vous avez comparé le nombre de
charleclerc avec le nombre de chars
russes
mais nous ne sommes pas une armée
d'agression nous sommes dans un modèle
purement défensif et que précisément
parce que nous avons notre dissuasion
nucléaire nous n'avons pas complètement
les mêmes besoins sur le terrain
conventionnel et de fait vous avez si
vous voulez supprimer la diffusion
nucléaire faut plutôt faire une des
amendements d'urgence de cibles à 1000
chars parce que pour le coup on
reviendrait dans une autre technique de
défense donc les modèles sont ainsi mais
je pense monsieur le Président Laurent
c'est pas vrai de dire que le travail
n'a pas été fait il a été fait il
aboutit sur un résultat que vous ne
partagez pas
mais il a été fait pardon par nos états
majeurs il a été fait devant vous en
commission je ne voudrais pas remuer le
couteau dans la plaie mais j'ai pas j'ai
répondu davantage à des questions sur
les marges frictionnelles avec un succès
limité je le note que de parler
justement du rôle de la France dans le
temps comme le sénateur tema elle a fait
tout à l'heure et pour le coup le débat
l'Assemblée nationale nous a permis de
le faire pendant 15 jours
mais seul la parole les militaires sont
justement prêts à avoir le débat y
compris sur la diffusion nucléaire mais
j'ai envie de dire c'est quoi le débat
au Parlement sur la loi de programmation
militaire si c'est pas aussi un débat
sur la défense nationale et je le disais
ce matin dans les colonnes d'un
quotidien moi en tant que citoyen
j'aurais préféré causes élections
législatives lors de l'Alliance déteste
qui ne concerne pas forcément cette
intergroupe ici mais il y est pas du
tout qu'il y ait une clarification sur
le positionnement des quatre formations
politiques qui forment la nupesse
aujourd'hui l'Assemblée nationale
j'étais bien en difficulté comme
ministre au banc à l'assemblée de me
retrouver dans une situation dans lequel
tout le monde avait un avis différent
sur le porte-avions la dissuasion les
coopérations européennes l'OTAN donc de
fait le débat avec la nation il est
important et moi je souhaite aussi que
lors des élections législatives ou
présidentielles on parle peut-être aussi
davantage de défense nationale à ce
moment-là en tout cas moi je retiens que
la technique du Livre Blanc tel qu'on
l'a connu je pense que malheureusement
elle est elle est à réinventer donc
peut-être dans le cadre de la de la CMP
s'il y a une rédaction que vous êtes
capable de
imaginer qui ouvre à une manière
d'associer mais aussi les élus locaux
les correspondants défenses dans les
collectivités locales les on parle de
dualité les entreprises qui ne sont pas
dans la BITD mais qui peuvent être
sollicités dans un schéma de résilience
je pense que là pour le coup moi je
partage complètement cette vue il est
important d'en marquer la nation mais je
pense qu'il faut qu'on soit imaginatif
pour le faire parce que sans quoi
malheureusement on passera à côté en
tout cas sur l'analyse stratégique elle
a été faite elle produit une copie et on
reviendra monsieur le sénateur themal
promis sur France et autant parce que
les interpellations que vous avez faites
sont très importantes pour comprendre
une partie de la structuration de la
copie merci alors je mets aux voiles
amendement du Gouvernement numéro 242
qui a reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient ils ont
pas adopté je mets aux voiles amendement
76 qui a reçu un avis favorable de la
commission défavorable du gouvernement
qui est pour contre qui s'abstient il
est donc adopté amendement 234 le
président Gontard
oui merci merci madame la Présidente il
s'agit d'un amendement qui vise à ce
qu'un débat parlementaire sur la
dissuasion nucléaire soit organisée à
l'avant la fin de cette loi de
programmation militaire c'est évidemment
un amendement plutôt plutôt d'appel mais
qui fait écho à ce que vient de dire
monsieur le monsieur le ministre je
pense qu'effectivement on a besoin
d'avoir cette réflexion on a besoin
d'avoir ce débat et notamment sur la
question de la dissuasion puisque on
parle dissuasion comme un fait un fait
accompli je pense qu'on a besoin de de
vraiment ouvrir le débat et de l'ouvrir
le même plus largement avec l'ensemble
de nos de nos concitoyens la question de
la dissuasion vous m'avez dit Monsieur
le Ministre qu'on était contre la
dissuasion je ne pense pas avoir dit ça
aucun moment et à aucun moment dans mon
intervention je dis qu'on se posait des
questions sur la question de la
dissuasion et je pense qu'on a on a
raison de se poser des questions comme
vous dites c'est entre 13 et 15% de sa
LPM ce n'est pas rien et qu'on a besoin
aussi de se projeter sur cette
dissuasion notamment dans l'évolution à
parfois tu contexte géopolitique mais
aussi du contexte technologique et qu'on
a évidemment besoin d'avoir cette
d'avoir cette réflexion et puis quand on
parle de dissuasion on n'est pas
forcément sur la dissuasion nucléaire il
y a aussi d'autres types de dissuasion
et donc en tout cas tous ces éléments là
doivent s'ouvrir et doivent on doit
avoir cette réflexion là et donc voilà
je pense que encore une fois il me
semble qu'on a besoin de poser ce débat
là on a besoin de pouvoir l'ouvrir et
également avec l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens parce que c'est vrai que la
dissuasion je pense que beaucoup quand
on en parle c'est vraiment pas quelque
chose qui est totalement compris et
totalement je dirais intégrer à la fois
dans son fonctionnement et à la fois
dans ces projection donc voilà c'était
plus un amendement d'appel mais en tout
cas je pense qu'on a réellement besoin
d'avoir ce débat
merci alors l'avis de la commission
monsieur le président
je note avec intérêt que le groupe du
président n'est pas totalement hostile à
la dissuasion avec cette subtilité
dissuasion dissuasion nucléaire enfin
pour nous quand on parle de dissuasion
c'est à peu près à quoi on pense bon
bien évidemment la Commission ne cesse
de travailler sur la dissuasion avec ses
rapports avec ses commissaires avec nos
auditions et donc nous nous poursuivrons
ce travail j'entends bien votre appel en
revanche dans votre amendement il y a
quelque chose qui n'était pas acceptable
c'est que le débat parlementaire que
vous proposiez incluait l'audition d'une
ONG en séance dans l'hémicycle donc ça
je pense que c'est pas vraiment
souhaitable et donc je vous propose de
retirer votre amendement on a bien
attendu cet appel et on continuera bien
évidemment au sein de la commission de
travailler sur ce sujet la vie du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre oui
madame la présente alors absolument
contre n'ont pas le débat mais le fait
qu'il ait lieu plus tard c'est la loi de
programmation militaire il faut l'avoir
maintenant
je vois la cavalerie aussi parce que
après on reproche au gouvernement une
insuffisance de préparation la RNS le
souci le cela très bien là on est là si
vous avez des questions sur la
dissuasion monsieur le Président poser
les mois et s'il faut prendre toute la
semaine et la semaine prochaine pour
avoir un débat sur mais on peut pas
aller je veux bien la passion pour les
marches la passion pour les marches
frictionnelles la passion pour les
rapports de charge au bout d'un moment
j'ai formé ce vœu en DG il y a un sujet
qui est central si des sensibilités
politiques c'est des parlementaires ont
des questions sur la dissuasion
nucléaire il faut le faire dès
maintenant et avant le vote donc moi si
vous avez des questions je les fais à
l'Assemblée vous le savez vous avez
suivi on a eu toute une nuit de débat
avec les députés écologistes les députés
de la France insoumise essentiellement
sur le sujet de l'addition et j'ai
justement je n'ai pas voulu et l'idée en
faisant défavorable etc je dis posez-moi
toutes les questions et on y a un débat
de bonne tenue et de bonne qualité sur
la diffusion nucléaire ou d'ailleurs
c'est là où je me suis saluer pas pour
donner des bons points des mauvais
points ça va sans dire mais Fabien
Roussel le député Roussel pardonnez-moi
a pris du temps pour réexpliquer la
position historique du Parti communiste
c'était intéressant donc moi je je mets
un avis défavorable ou de retrait à cet
amendement mais si vous souhaitez poser
des questions sur la dissuasion mais je
le présenta faites le dès maintenant
pour ne pas dans trois mois ou dans un
an entendre dire que la LPM n'aura pas
permis de évoquer toutes les questions
et qu'il aurait fallu faire un livre
blanc ça pour le coup c'est le moment
posant les questions sur la dissuasion
merci monsieur le Président Gontard
je remercie monsieur le ministre
m'autoriser à poser des questions sur je
pense qu'en tout cas cet amendement la
preuve c'est qu'il avait il avait son
son intérêt je pense sur la question de
la dissuasion oui c'est quelque chose
d'important enfin je veux dire on peut
pas juste dire c'est comme ça c'est un
fait accompli et voilà je pense que oui
aujourd'hui on a ce système de
dissuasion nucléaire et pas complètement
dingue je sais bien qu'on va pas
l'arrêter du jour au lendemain ça il y a
pas de souci mais par contre de
réfléchir à qu'est-ce que c'est que
cette dissuasion et quel objectif en lui
donne et quelle orientation également
lui donne je veux dire est-ce que c'est
toujours plus de dissuasion est-ce que
la France indique oriente justement sur
une dénucléarisation et donne l'exemple
et en tout cas réfléchi avec l'ensemble
de ses partenaires voilà l'ensemble de
ces de ces questions donc effectivement
sur la question de la dissuasion je
pense qu'il y a vraiment un débat et une
réflexion une réflexion à avoir tout à
l'heure je vous ai posé des questions
vous m'avez dit 13 % 15 % et je vous ai
demandé justement qu'est-ce qu'il y
avait dedans est-ce que c'était
justement du remplacement sur des armes
liées à la dissuasion où est-ce que
c'était une évolution est-ce qu'on
donnait une puissance supplémentaire
vous m'avez dit secret défense donc moi
je veux bien mais on a besoin aussi
d'avoir ces éléments là et ces
orientations là donc voilà je pense en
tout cas le ce déballage il me semble
pas
inutile en tout cas je pense pas qu'il
faut le prendre comme ça en se disant
bon bah c'est bon et puis mettre des
bons points et des mauvais points je
pense que dans la population tout le
monde se pose des questions et a le
droit aussi d'avoir des réponses et des
réflexions en tout cas ça serait une
erreur de pas réfléchir à ça
si monsieur le ministre
moi je suis bien d'accord avec toute la
dernière partie de votre intervention il
faut avoir le débat parce que il en va
de l'acceptabilité aussi
sociétale je lui dis notamment pour les
autres parlementaires qui sont vraiment
pour la dissuasion nucléaire en disant
c'est comme ça ça fonctionne circulaire
rien à voir ce n'est pas une bonne
manière justement de défendre la
diffusion de nucléaire c'est pour ça que
je je n'ai pas vous autoriser à me poser
des questions vous êtes parlementaire en
revanche je veux pas qu'on passe à côté
du débat parce que sinon ça sera pour
mieux se plaindre qu'il n'est pas eu
lieu et ça je trouve que c'est pas
raisonnable parce que si nous aussi au
Sénat on en débapas qui vend débattre à
notre place très franchement ça n'a pas
de n'a pas de sens vous avez posé une
question précise c'est au fond 13%
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
moi j'amènerai quand même plusieurs
commentaires un parmi les puissances
dotées déclarées toutes ne sont pas des
démocraties et donc par définition il
nous faut nous comparer avec les trois
démocraties nucléaires déclarées les
États-Unis d'Amérique la Grande-Bretagne
et la France 3 Pays d'ailleurs membres
de l'OTAN laquelle France n'est pas
membre de la planification nucléaire de
l'OTAN ce qui est un des éléments aussi
clé dans notre héritage évidemment
golien parmi ces trois démocraties
nucléaires je parle même pas de la Chine
ou de la Russie
quel est le pays qui a la doctrine la
plus lisible et la plus publique il se
trouve que c'est la France avec cette
permanence depuis générale de Gaulle le
sénateur thermal a rappelé les
engagements du Président Mitterrand et
du président Hollande il y a quand même
une grande constance française non mais
moi j'aime une histoire dans sa réalité
je l'ai fait mais il est pas de gauche
Jacques Chirac bon enfin
et donc que Jacques Chirac soit dans la
fidélité à ce que faisait le général de
Gaulle me semble pas surprenant sous le
contrôle de celui qui fut son secrétaire
général monsieur le ministre bas ce que
je voulais souligner c'est que les
présidents Hollande et Mitterrand était
aussi dans cette continuité ça pour le
coup c'est ce que voulait dire le Center
mal tout à l'heure et cette doctrine
qu'est-ce qu'elle dit que par définition
on est pour défendre nos intérêts vitaux
d'une menace
venant d'un état
ce qui donc déjà créé une voûte
évidemment des éléments de contournement
potentiel de cette voûte c'est ce que
j'indiquais en discussion générale
que cette doctrine elle pointait du
doigt le fait qu'elle était strictement
défensive et suffisante et donc si votre
question sous-jacente c'est mais c'est
13% là dans un budget global qui
augmente est-ce que ça remet en cause le
fait que notre dissuasion nucléaire est
défensive et suffisante la réponse est
non monsieur le sénateur voilà et que
donc ces crédits sont des crédits de
renouvellement de renouvellement dans
des conditions opérationnelles qui
changent parce que évidemment les
différentes menaces de l'adversaire nous
conduisent à devoir faire attention je
donne un exemple plein de bon sens et en
source ouverte l'acoustique des
sous-marins la signature acoustique d'un
sous-marin mais il est évident que ce
n'est le troisième génération seront
plus discrets que ceux de la deuxième
génération et que par définition c'est
un saut technologique et que par
définition ça coûte de l'argent c'est un
exemple sur les CNLE ça pourrait être le
cas sur d'autres sur d'autres types donc
je vais pas être plus long mais en tout
cas il y a certes du secret défense mais
il n'est pas fait pour évacuer le débat
sur le fond
après on a eu un bon débat avec le Parti
communiste français à l'Assemblée
nationale sur
TNP en quoi la France est engagée dans
la non prolifération ce qui n'est pas
complètement la même chose que d'être
dans une logique d'interdiction que nous
combattons parce que l'interdiction
c'est le désarmement et c'est là où avec
le Parti communiste on s'est affronté
entre guillemets entre des armements
multilatérales mais qui au fond dans les
faits on le sait tous est unilatéral
c'est là où Fabien Roussel a eu des
propos évidemment intéressant parce
qu'il a voulu aussi et je connais les
choses bref en tout cas je pense que
c'est un débat qui est clé et si on ne
l'a pas pendant la voie de programmation
militaire pardon on peut toujours
renvoyer au calendrier ou dans un débat
spécifique on l'aura pas plus ça c'est
vraiment le coeur de la PM hier
aujourd'hui demain et qui permet aussi
de regarder ce que la dissuasion de
couvre pas et c'est pour ça que je suis
parfois un peu dur et engagé sur les
nouvelles menaces parce que par
définition une puissance dotée c'est
vulnérabilité elles sont évidemment dans
des espaces beaucoup plus hybrides
beaucoup plus Sourn ois beaucoup plus
pernicieux pas de face mais sur les
côtés c'est évidemment la question du
cyber du spatial que j'évoquais
précédemment merci Monsieur Laurent
ce président Laurent pardon
oui merci
bon c'est effectivement un débat très
important on va on rebondira dans ce
débat plusieurs fois parce qu'il y a
d'autres amendements dans la discussion
qui nous permettront d'aborder certains
aspects comme la question de la non
prolifération et du Traité
d'interdiction des armes nucléaires
parce que on a fait des amendements
là-dessus mais je pense que au moins
l'échange qu'on a là elle mérite de dire
que il y a besoin effectivement d'un
débat national sur ces questions et la
situation internationale nous y invite
parce que il faut avoir un débat avec la
nation sur cette question très
importante et vous le dites vous-même
d'une certaine manière
la réponse que la première réponse que
vous nous avez fait tout à l'heure vous
abritant derrière le secret défense je
vous mets au défi de vous en tenir à
cette question si vous étiez face à une
salle de 500 français qui vous interroge
là-dessus vous seriez obligé de rentrer
dans plus de détails donc je vois pas
pourquoi nous les parlementaires on
devrait s'en tenir à une réponse qui dit
secret de la défense point barre alors
que nous débattons de cette question
avec beaucoup de citoyens deuxièmement
les la composante les composantes de la
dissuasion ont connu des évolutions
déjà des évolutions significatives
depuis la création de la dissuasion
française le format de notre dissuasion
n'a pas toujours été le même il a évolué
donc nous pouvons nous poser des
questions sur le format de la dissuasion
ou en tout cas demander des débats ou
avoir des débats sur ces questions-là
sont être renvoyés à des gens qui sont
des irresponsables par rapport à cette
question puisque ces questions là ces
évolutions là ont eu lieu sous la
conduite de gouvernement que à l'époque
j'imagine vous souteniez ardemment donc
ce sont des questions des questions
sérieuses et c'est ces questions que
nous voulons nous voulons poser et il y
a la dissuasion et ses composantes et
puis des débats annexes je dirais enfin
qui sont à côté mais qui sont liés celui
du porte-avion est lié parce que plus on
en avance dans le débat sur le
porte-avion et plus l'argument de la
continuité de la filière nucléaire
après on reproche au gouvernement que il
n'y aurait pas suffisamment de débats
que les choses seraient pas suffisamment
éclairées que la réflexion stratégique
qui aurait présidé ou précédé la LPM
aurait été bâclée donc non
s'il le faut je serai là jusqu'au bout
parce que précisément
non non mais je le dis parce que je mets
en cohérence aussi l'ensemble de ce que
j'ai pu entendre depuis six mois sur la
la manière dont tu as été imaginé cette
loi de programmation militaire monsieur
le Président Laurent sur le secret
défense les choses sont assez simples il
y a des choses qui sont classifiées des
choses qui ne sont pas posez-moi toutes
les questions et c'est à moi de faire le
tri entre ce que j'ai le droit de dire
de ce que la loi que le Parlement a voté
m'autorise à dire pour être précis c'est
pas c'est pas ma discrétion ce qui est
classifié ou pas ça m'a donné tout ça a
une base légale ce que j'ai le droit de
dire est-ce que je n'ai pas le droit de
dire et d'ailleurs objectivement on peut
quand même dire beaucoup de choses si on
est honnête et si on va même au-delà je
le prends cet engagement devant le
président une séance de commission qui
ne serait pas retransmise ne me se
passerait pas de dévoiler des secrets
défenses mais me permettrait d'être
encore plus à l'aise pour parler d'un
certain nombre de cas pratiques ou de
situations sur lequel je n'ai pas
forcément envie de susciter une réaction
de tel ou tel ambassade ou vous devez
l'hôtel Le partenaire pour dire les
choses très clairement mais oui le
format de la dissuasion à évoluer dans
le temps déjà avec l'apparition plus la
disparition de ce qu'on a appelé
abusivement le nucléaire tactique
c'était plutôt dans sa composante armée
de terre la fermeture d'Albion dans les
années 90 et pourquoi c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure dissolution du
pack de Varsovie un certain nombre de de
décisions ont été prises la profession
de l'armée de terre enfin de désarmée en
général pardonnez-moi qui a beaucoup
touché l'armée de terre mais aussi
évidemment le fait de toucher à la
composante et là dans la loi de
programmation militaire telle que nous
vous la proposons vous n'avez pas de
modification en tant que tel du format
de la dissuasion composante aérienne les
faces composantes
océaniques la fosse avec des
modifications de matériel mais toujours
sur les mêmes cibles Cat et c'est né le
et une demi composante comme on le dit
là aussi c'est pas très élégant pour la
Fanu qui peut être embarqué ou non sur
le porte-avion mais il n'y a pas de
modification de la doctrine en tant que
tel elle a été réaffirmée par le
Président de la République à l'école de
guerre lors d'un discours c'est un peu
la tradition qui fait que chaque
quinquennat au septa le chef de l'État
quel qu'il soit précisé des choses si ce
n'est que le Président on regarde des
circonstances a été amené en parler plus
que à la coutumée aussi pour répondre à
ce qui a été dit à l'instant sur la
nécessaire compréhension et notamment
des phrases comme les intérêts vitaux
ont une dimension européenne ça fait 15
ans que c'est le cas et c'est affiché
très clairement dans la doctrine
française mais qui est un des éléments
qu'on a répété de nombreuses reprises
ces derniers temps ce qui est aussi un
des moyens de répondre au sénateur t'es
mal donc il y a beaucoup de sujets qui
sont complètement source ouvertes qui
sont enseignées l'école de guerre au
chênes pour les parlementaires qui ont
été auditeurs à l'IHEDN donc il y a pas
de raison qu'on fasse moins ici mais
c'est bien pour ça mais raison parce que
Hervé c'est pour ça que moi je veux
redire que je suis disponible pour le
faire d'ores et déjà ici et maintenant
et de ne pas le renvoyer à plus tard
sans quoi je sais aussi désormais
d'expérience qu'on regrettera de pas
l'avoir fait maintenant ensuite merci
voilà seulement 234 qui a reçu donc un
avis défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'absire n'est donc pas adopté
l'article 7 je le mets aux voix qui est
pour contre qui s'abstient il est donc
adopté mes chers collègues je vais
suspendre la séance et elle sera reprise
à 21h30 pour la suite de l'examen de ce
texte la séance est suspendue